well the source of energy at the origin
of life is the reaction between carbon
dioxide and hydrogen and amazingly most
of these reactions are
exergonic which is to say they release
energy this if you have hydrogen and co2
and you put them together in a falcon
tube and you warm it up to say 50
degrees centigrade and you put in a
couple of catalysts and you shake it
nothing's gonna happen but
thermodynamically
that is less stable two gases hydrogen
and co2 is less stable than cells what
should happen is you get cells coming
out why doesn't that happen is because
of the kinetic barriers it's because
that's where you need the spark
the following is a conversation with
nick lane a biochemist at university
college london and author of some of my
favorite books on biology science and
life
ever written
including his two most recent titled
transformer the deep chemistry of life
and death
and
the vital question
why is life the way it is
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's nick
lane
let's start with perhaps the most
mysterious the most interesting question
that uh we
little humans can ask of ourselves how
did life originate on earth you could
you could ask anybody working on the
subject
and you'll get a different answer from
all of them they will be pretty
passionately held
opinions and their opinions grounded in
science
um
but they're still really at this point
their opinions because there's so much
stuff to know
that all we can ever do is get a kind of
a small slice of it and it's the context
which matters so i can give you my
answer
my answer is
from a biologist's point of view
that has been missing from the equation
over decades
which is well what does life do on earth
what what why is it this way why is it
made of cells why is it made of carbon
why does it why is it powered by
electrical charges on membranes there's
all these interesting questions about
cells
that if you then look to see well is
there an environment on earth on the
early earth four billion years ago it
kind of matches the requirements of
cells well there is one there's a very
obvious one it's basically created by
whenever
you have a wet rocky planet you get
these hydrothermal vents
which generate
hydrogen gas in bucket loads and
electrical charges on kind of cell-like
pores
that can can drive the kind of chemistry
that life does so it seems so beautiful
and so
so obvious
um that
i've spent the last 10 years or more
trying to do experiments it turns out to
be difficult of course everything's more
difficult than you ever thought it was
going to be
but it looks i would say more true
rather than less true over that 10-year
period i think i have to take a step
back every now and then and think hang
on a minute where's this going uh i'm
happy it's going in a sensible direction
and i think then you have these other
interesting dilemmas i mean i'm often
accused of being
too focused on life on earth
too kind of
narrow-minded and inward looking you
might say i'm think i'm talking about
carbon i'm talking about cells and maybe
you or plenty of people can say to me ah
yeah but life can be anything i have no
imagination and maybe they're right but
unless we can say why life here is this
way and if those reasons are fundamental
reasons or if they're just trivial
reasons then we can't answer that
question um so so i think they're
fundamental reasons and i think we need
to worry about them yeah there might be
some deep truth to the puzzle here on
earth that will resonate with
other puzzles elsewhere that will
solving this particular puzzle will give
us that deeper truth so what to this
puzzle you said
vents
hydrogen
wet so
chemically what is the potion here how
important is oxygen you wrote a book
about this yeah and i actually just came
straight here from a conference where i
was sharing a session on whether oxygen
matters or not in the history of life of
course it matters
but it matters most of the origin of
life to be not there um
as i see it we have this
i mean life is made of carbon basically
primarily um organic molecules with
carbon-carbon bonds
and
the building block the lego brick that
we take out of the air or take out of
the oceans is carbon dioxide and to turn
carbon dioxide into organic molecules we
need to strap on hydrogen and so we need
an and this is basically what life
is doing it's hydrogenating carbon
dioxide it's taking the hydrogen the
bubbles out of the earth in these
hydrothermal vents and it sticks it on
co2
um and it's kind of really as simple as
that um and actually thermodynamically
there's the the thing that i find most
troubling
is that you if you do these experiments
in the lab the molecules you get are
exactly the molecules that we see at the
heart of biochemistry in the heart of
life is there something to be said about
the earliest origins of that
little uh
potion
that chemical process
what really is the spark there
there isn't
a spark um
there is a continuous chemical reaction
and there is kind of a spark but it's a
continuous electrical charge which helps
drive that reaction so literally spark
uh well the charge at least but yes i
mean a spark in that sense is um
we're we tend to think of in terms of
frankenstein we tend to think in terms
of electricity and one one moment you
zap something and it comes alive and
what does that really mean you've it's
come alive and now what's sustaining it
well
we are sustained by oxygen by this
continuous chemical reaction
and if you put a plastic bag on your
head then you've got a minute or
something before it's all over so some
way of being able to leverage a source
of energy well the source of energy at
the origin of life is the reaction
between carbon dioxide and hydrogen and
amazingly most of these reactions are
exergonic which is to say they release
energy this if you have hydrogen and co2
and you put them together in a falcon
tube and you warm it up to say 50
degrees centigrade and you put in a
couple of catalysts and you shake it
nothing's gonna happen but
thermodynamically
that is less stable two gases hydrogen
and co2 is less stable than cells what
should happen is you get cells coming
out um
so why doesn't that happen is because of
the kinetic barriers is because that's
where you need the spark
is it possible that life originated
multiple times on earth
the way you describe it you make it
sound so easy
there's a long distance to go from the
first bits of prebiotic chemistry to say
molecular machines like ribosomes is
that the first
thing that you would say is life
like if i introduce you to the two of
you at a party you would say that's a
living thing
i would say as soon as we introduce
genes information
into systems that are growing anyway so
i i would i would talk about growing
protocells as soon as we in
introduce even random bits of
information into
into there
i'm thinking about rna molecules for
example it doesn't have to have any
information it can be completely random
sequence but if it's introduced into a
system which is in any case growing and
doubling itself and reproducing itself
then any changes in that sequence that
allow it to do so better or worse are
now selected by perfectly normal natural
selection but the system so that's when
it becomes alive to my mind that's
encompassed into like um
an object
that
keeps information and involves that
information over time or changes that
information over time yes exactly in
response to that so it's always part of
a cell system from the very beginning so
is your sense that it started only once
because it's difficult or is it possibly
started in multiple locations on earth
it's possible to start on multiple
occasions
um
there's two provisos to that one of them
is
oxygen
makes it
impossible really for life to start so
as soon as we've got oxygen in the
atmosphere then life isn't going to keep
starting over so i often get asked by
people you know why can't we have life
starting if it's so easy why can't i
start in these vents now and the answer
is you've got if you want hydrogen to
react with co2 and there's oxygen there
hydrogen reacts with oxygen instead it's
just you know you you get an explosive
reaction that way it's rocket fuel so
it's never going to happen but the other
for the origin of life earlier than that
all we know
is that there's a single common ancestor
for all of life there could have been
multiple origins and they all just
disappeared um
but there's a very interesting deep
split in life between bacteria and what
are called archaea which look just the
same as bacteria
and they're not quite as diverse but
nearly and they are very different in
their biochemistry and so any
explanation for the origin of life has
to account as well for why they're so
different and yet so similar and that
makes me think that life probably did
arise only once
can you describe the difference that's
interesting there
how they're similar how they're
different well they're different in uh
in their membranes primarily they're
different in things like dna replication
they use completely different enzymes
and the genes behind it for replicating
dna so they both have membranes both
have dna replication yes the process of
that is different they have d they both
have dna the genetic code is identical
in them both the way in which it's uh
transcribed into rna into the copy of a
gene and the way that that's then
translated into a protein that's all
basically the same in both these groups
so they clearly share
a common ancestor it's just that they're
different in fundamental ways as well
and if you think about what kind of
processes could drive that divergence
very early on
um i can think about it in terms of
membranes in terms of the electrical
charges on membranes and it's that that
makes me think that uh there's probably
probably many unsuccessful attempts at
only one really successful attempt
can you explain why that divergence
makes you think there's one answer uh
one common ancestor
okay can you describe that intuition i'm
a little bit unclear about why the diver
like the leap from the divergence
means there's one
do you mean like the divergence
indicates that there was a big invention
at that time yes
if it was if if you've got
as i imagine it you have a common
ancestor living in a hydrothermal vent
let's say there are you know millions of
vents and millions of potential common
ancestors living in all of those vents
but only one of them makes it out first
then you could imagine that that cell is
then going to kind of take over the
world and and wipe out everything else
and so you what you would see would be a
single common ancestor for all of life
but with you know lots lots of different
vent systems all kind of
vying to create the first life forms you
might say so this thing is a cell a
single cell well
we're always talking about populations
of cells but yes
these are cell organisms but the
fundamental
life form is a single cell
right so like
or
so they're always together
but they're alone together
yeah there's a machinery in each one
individual component that if left by
itself would still
work yes yes yes it's the unit of
selection is a single cell but selection
operates over generations and changes
over generations in populations of cells
so it would be impossible to say that a
cell is the unit of selection in the
sense that
you unless you have a population you
can't evolve you can't change
right but there was one
chuck norris
it's an american reference yeah uh cell
that made it out of the vents
right or
like the first one so imagine then
there's one cell gets out and it takes
over the world it gets out in the water
it's like floating around we're deep in
the ocean somewhere yeah but actually
two cells got out
um and they appear to have got out from
the same
vent
because they both share the same code
and everything else so unless all the
you know we've got a million different
common ancestors in in all these
different vents so either they all have
the same code and two cells
spontaneously merge from different
places or
two two different cells fundamentally
different cells came from the same place
so either way what are the constraints
that say not just one came out or not
half a million came out but two
came out that's kind of a bit strange uh
so how did they come out well they come
out because
what you're doing inside event is you're
relying on the electrical charges down
there to power this reaction between
hydrogen and co2 to make yourself grow
and when you leave the vent you've got
to do that yourself you've got to power
up your own membrane and so the question
is well how do you power up your own
membrane
and the answer is well you need to pump
you need to pump ions to give an
electrical charge on the membrane so
what do the pumps look like well the
pumps look different in these two groups
it's as if they they both emerge from a
common ancestor as soon as you've got
that ancestor things move very quickly
um and
and divergently why does the dna
replication look different well it's
joined to the membrane the membranes are
different the dna replication is
different because it's joined to a
different kind of membrane so there's
interesting you know this this is detail
you may say but it's also fundamental
because it's about the two big divergent
groups of life on earth that seem to
have diverged really early on it all
started from
one organism
and then
that organs just start replicating the
heck out of itself
with some mutation of the dna so like
there's some um there's a competition
through the process of evolution they're
not like trying to beat each other up
they're just
they're just trying to live they just
replicate us
yeah well you know let's not minimize
their yeah
there's no sense of trying to survive
they're replicating i mean there's no
sense in which they're trying to do
anything they're just a kind of an
outgrowth of the earth you might say of
course the aliens would describe us
humans in that same way
they might be right primitive life it's
just it's just ants that are hairless
mostly hairless overgrown ants overgrown
ants okay um what do you think about the
idea of
panspermia that
the theory that life did not originate
on earth and was planted here from outer
space
or pseudo panspermia which is like the
basic ingredients the magic that you
mentioned was planted here from
elsewhere in space
i don't find them helpful that's not to
say they're wrong
uh
so so pseudotranspermia the idea that
you know the chemicals the amino acids
the nucleotides are being delivered from
space well we know that happens it's
unequivocal they're delivered on
meteorites comets and so on
um
so what do they do next that's to me the
question and well what they do is they
stock a soup like presumably they land
in a pond or in an ocean or wherever
they land
and then you end up with a you know best
possible case scenario is you end up
with a super nucleotides and amino acids
and then you have to say so now what
happens and the answer is oh well they
have to go
become alive so how did they do that you
may as well say then a miracle happened
i don't believe in soup
i i think what we have in a vent is a
continuous conversion a continuous
growth a continuous reaction continuous
converting a flow of molecules into more
of yourself you might say even if it's a
small bit so you've you've got
you've got a kind of continuous
self-organization and growth from the
very beginning you never have that in a
soup
isn't
the entire universe and living organisms
in the universe isn't it just uh
soup all the way down isn't it also no
no i mean soup almost by definition
doesn't have a structure
but soup is a collection of ingredients
that are like randomly
yeah they're not i mean
we have chemistry going on here we have
metadata forming which are which are you
know effective oil water interactions
okay so it feels like there's a
direction to a process like a director
there are
there are directions to processes yeah
and if you are com if you're starting
with co2 and you've got two reactive
fluids being brought together and they
they react what are they going to make
well they they make carboxylic acids
which include the fatty acids that make
up the cell membranes and and they form
directly into bilayer membranes they
form like soap bubbles it's spontaneous
organization
caused by the nature of the molecules
and and those things are capable of
growing and are capable in effect of
being selected even before there are
genes we have this so we have a lot of
order and that order is coming from
thermodynamics and the thermodynamics is
always about increasing the entropy of
the universe but if you have
if you have oil and water and they're
separating you're increasing the entropy
of the universe even though you've got
some order which is the soap and the
water are not not miscible now
to come back to your first
question about um panspermia properly
um
that just pushes the question somewhere
else that just even if it's true maybe
life did start on earth by panspermia
but but so what are the principles
that govern the emergence of life on any
planet we it's an assumption that life
started here and it's an assumption that
it you know it started in a hydrothermal
vent or it started in a terrestrial
geothermal system the question is can we
work out a testable sequence of events
that would lead from one to the other
one and then test it and see if there's
any truth in it or not with panspermia
you can't do any of that but the the
fundamental question of past sperm is do
we have
the machine here on earth to build life
is the vents enough
is
oxygen and hydrogen
and whatever the heck else we want and
some source of energy and heat is that
enough to build life
or
well that's
of course you would say that as a human
uh but there could be aliens right now
chuckling at that idea maybe you need
some special um
special sauce
special elsewhere sauce your senses
we have everything i mean this is
precisely the the question so i i like
to when when i'm talking in schools i
like to start out with the idea of we
make we can make a time machine
we go back four billion years and we go
to these environments that people talk
about we go to a deep sea hydrothermal
event we go to a kind of yellowstone
park type
place environment
and we find some slime that looks like
we can we can test it it's made of
organic molecules
it's got a structure which is not
obviously cells but you know it's is is
this a stepping stone on the way to life
or not yeah how do we know
unless we've got an intellectual
framework that says this is this is a
stepping stone and that's not us that
you know we'd never know we wouldn't
know which environment to go to what to
look for how to say this so all we can
ever hope for because we're never going
to build that time machine is to have an
intellectual framework that can explain
step by step experiment by experiment
how we go from a sterile inorganic
planet to living cells as we know them
and in that framework every time you
have a choice it could be this way or it
could be that way or you know there's
lots of
possible forks down that road um
did it have to be that way could it have
been the other way and would that have
given you life with very different
properties
um and so if you if you come up with a
you know it's a long hypothesis because
as i say we're going from really simple
prebiotic chemistry all the way through
to genes and molecular machines that's a
long long pathway and nobody in the
field would agree on the order in which
these things happened which is not a bad
thing because it means that you have to
go out and do some experiments and try
and demonstrate that it's possible or
not possible it's so
freaking amazing
that it happened though
it feels
like there's a direction to the thing
can you try to
answer
from a framework perspective of what is
life
so you said there's some order
and yet
there's complexity
so it's not perfectly ordered it's not
boring there's still some fun in it and
it also feels like the processes have a
direction
through the selection mechanism they
seem to be
building something always better
always improving i mean maybe it's i
mean that's a perception that's our
romanticization of things are always
better
things are getting better we'd like to
believe that i mean you think about the
world from the point of view of bacteria
and bacteria are the first things to
emerge from whatever environment they
came from and they dominated the planet
very very quickly and they haven't
really changed four billion years later
they look exactly the same so about four
billion years ago
bacteria started to
to really run the show
and then
nothing happened for a while nothing
happened for two billion years yep then
after two billion years we see another
single event origin if you like of of
our own type of cell the eukaryotic cell
so cells with a nucleus and loss of
stuff going on inside
another singular origin it only happened
once in the history of life on earth
maybe it happened multiple times and
there's no evidence everything just
disappeared but we have to at least
take it seriously
that there's
something that stops bacteria from
becoming more complex because they
didn't you know that's a fact that they
emerged
four billion years ago and something
happened two billion years ago but the
bacteria themselves didn't change they
remain bacterial so there is no
trajectory necessary trajectory towards
great complexity in human beings at the
end of it it's very easy to imagine that
without photosynthesis arising or
without eukaryotes arising that a planet
could be full of bacteria and nothing
else
we'll get to that because that's a
brilliant invention and there's a few
brilliant invention along the way but
what is life
if you were to show up on earth but to
take that time machine and you said
asking yourself the question is this a
stepping stone towards life
as you step along
when you see the early bacteria
how would you know it's life
is and then this is really important
question when you go to other planets
and look for life
like what
uh what is the framework of telling the
difference between a rock
and a bacteria
i mean the question's kind of both
impossible to answer and trivial at the
same time and i don't like to answer it
because i don't think there is an answer
i think we're trying to describe one
question approaching me there's no
answer so there's no i mean there's lots
of there are at least 40 or 50 different
definitions of life out there and most
of them are
well convincingly obviously bad in one
way or another
um uh i mean there's this phrase i i can
never remember the exact words that
people use but there's a nasa uh working
definition of life uh which more or less
has a a system which is capable of
of a self-sustaining system capable of
evolution or something along those lines
and i immediately have a problem with
the word self-sustaining because it's
sustained by the environment and
i know what they're getting at i know
what they're trying to say but but i
pick a hole in that and there's you know
there's always wags who say but you know
by that definition a rabbit is not alive
only a pair of rabbits would be alive
because a single rabbit is incapable of
copying yourself
there's all kinds of pedantic
silly but also important objections to
any hypothesis the real question is what
what is you know
we can argue all day or people do argue
all day about is is a virus alive or not
and it depends on the content but most
biologists could not agree about that so
then what about a jumping gene a retro
element or something like this even
simpler than a virus but it's capable of
converting its environment into a copy
of itself
and that's about as close it's not a
definition but this is a kind of a
description of life
is that it's it's able to
parasitize the environment and that goes
for plants as well as animals and
bacteria and viruses
um to make a a relatively exact copy of
themselves informationally exact copy of
themselves by the way it doesn't really
have to be
a copy of itself right it just has to be
you have to create something
that's interesting
the way evolution is
so it is extremely powerful process of
evolution which is basically make a copy
yourself and sometimes mess up a little
bit okay that seems to work really well
i wonder if it's possible to
mess up big time mess up big time as a
standard that's the default uh it's
called the hopeful monster and you know
this doesn't work
in principle it can actually it turns
out i would say that this is due a
re-emergence this is some amazing work
from michael levine i don't know if you
came across him but uh you if you
haven't interviewed him you should
interview him yeah uh yeah
about yeah i'm
talking to him in a few days oh
fantastic i mentioned off yes there's
some people that anja if i may mention
uh andre kapathi is a friend who's
really admired in the ai community said
you absolutely must talk
to to michael and to nick this is so
this of course i'm a huge fan of yours
so i'm really fortunate that we can
actually make this happen anyway
well michael levin is doing amazing work
uh basically about the way in which
electrical fields control development um
and he's done some work with planarian
worms so flatworms well he'll tell you
all about this so i won't say any more
than the minimum but basically you can
cut their head off and they'll redevelop
a different
a new head but the head that they
develop depends if you knock out just
one
um
one one iron pump in a membrane so you
change the electrical circuitry just a
little bit you can come up with a
completely different head it can be a
head which is similar to those that
diverged 150 million years ago or it can
be a head which no one's ever seen
before a different kind of of head um
now that is really you might say a
hopeful monster this is a kind of leap
into a different direction the only
question for natural selection is does
it work is the change itself
feasible as a single change and the
answer is yes it's just a small change
to a single gene and the second thing is
it gives rise to a completely different
morphology does it work and if it works
that can easily be
a shift
it but for it to be a speciation for it
to
to continue for it to to give rise to a
different morphology over time
then it has to be perpetuated so that
shift that change in the
in in that one gene
has to work well enough that it is
selected and it goes on and copied
enough times to where you can really
test it and so the likelihood it would
be lost but but there will be some
occasions where it survives and yes the
idea that we can have sudden fairly
abrupt changes in evolution i think it's
time for a rebirth what about this idea
that
kind of trying to
mathematize
a definition of life and saying how many
steps
the shortest amount of steps it takes to
build the thing almost like an
engineering view of it
i like that view
um because i think that in a sense
that's not very far away from what it
what what what a hypothesis needs to do
to be a testable hypothesis for the
origin of life you need to spell out
here's here's each step
and here's the experiment to do for each
step
the idea that we can do it in the lab
some people say oh well i've you know
we'll have created life within five
years but you know ask them what they
mean by life
um
we have a planet four billion years ago
with these vent systems across the
entire surface of the planet and we have
millions of years if we wanted i have a
feeling that we're not talking about
millions of years i have a feeling we're
talking about
maybe millions of nanoseconds or
picoseconds we're talking about
chemistry which is happening quickly
but we still need to constrain those
steps but we've got a you know a planet
uh doing similar chemistry you asked
about a trajectory the trajectory is the
planetary trajectory the planet has
properties it's basically it's got a lot
of iron at the center of it it's got a
lot of electrons at the center of it
it's more oxidized on the outside partly
because of the sun and partly because
the heat of volcanoes puts out oxidized
gases so
the planet is a battery it's a giant
battery um
and we have a flow of electrons going
from inside to outside in these
hydrothermal vents and that's the same
topology that a cell has a cell is
basically just a micro version of the
planet um
and it's uh
there is a trajectory in all of that and
there's an inevitability that certain
types of chemical reaction are going to
be favored over others and there's an
inevitability in
in what happens in water the chemistry
that happens in water some
some will be miscible with water and
will form membranes and will form
insoluble structures and you know
water's a
nobody really understands water very
well
um and it's uh it's another big question
for experiments on the origin of life
what do you put it in
what kind of structure do we want to
induce in this water because the last
thing is likely to be is just kind of
bulk bulk water
how fundamental is water to life would
you say i would say pretty fundamental
um
i wouldn't like to say it's impossible
for life to start any other way
but
water is everywhere
water is extremely good at what it does
and carbon carbon works in water
especially well so those things and
carbon is everywhere so those things
together make me think probabilistically
if we found a thousand life forms
995 of them would be carbon-based and
living in water
now the reverse question if you found a
puddle of water elsewhere and some
carbon
no just a puddle of water is a pot of
water
a pretty damn good indication that life
has
is either exists here
or
has once existed here no
so it doesn't work the other way
i think you need a living planet
you need a planet which is capable of
turning over its surface it needs to be
a planet with water it needs to be
capable of of
bringing those electrons from inside to
the outside it needs to turn over its
surface it needs to make that water work
and turn it into hydrogen so i think you
need a living planet but once you've got
the living planet i think the rest of it
uh is kind of thermodynamics all the way
so if you were to run earth over a
million times
up to this point
maybe beyond to the end let's run it to
the end
uh what is it uh how much variety is
there you kind of spoke to this
trajectory that the environment dictates
like chemically i don't know in which
other way
um spiritually
like dictates kind of the direction of
this giant machine that seems uh chaotic
but it does seem to have order in the
steps it's taking
uh how much
how often will life
how often will bacteria emerge how often
will something like humans emerge how
much variety do you think there would be
i think at the level of bacteria
not much variety i think we would get
that's how many times you say you want
to run it a million times
um i would say at least a few hundred
thousand will get bacteria again oh wow
um nice because i i think there's some
level of inevitability that a wet rocky
planet will give rise through
through the same processes
to something very close i i think this
is not something i'd have thought a few
years ago but we're working with a phd
student of mine stuart harrison he's
been thinking about the genetic code and
we've just been publishing on that um
there are patterns that you can discern
in the co or he has discerned in the
code
that if you if you think about them in
terms of we start with co2 and hydrogen
and these are the first steps of
biochemistry you come up with a code
which is very similar to the code that
we see
so it wouldn't surprise me any longer if
we found life on mars and it had a
genetic code that was not very different
to the genetic code that we have here
without it just being transferred across
some inevitability about the whole of
the beginnings of life in my view that's
really promising because if the basic
chemistry is tightly linked to the
genetic code
that means
we can interact with other life if it
exists
potentially
that's that's really exciting if that's
if that's the case okay but then
bacteria we've got then we've got
bacteria yeah um
how easy is photosynthesis
much harder i would say
let's actually go there let's let's go
through the inventions yeah um what is
photosynthesis
and why is it hard well there are
different
forms
i mean basically you're taking hydrogen
and you're sticking it onto co2 and it's
powered by the sun the question is where
are you taking the hydrogen from
and in photosynthesis that we know in
plants it's coming from water so you're
using the power of the sun to split
water take out the hydrogen stick it
onto co2 and the oxygen is a waste
product and you just throw it out throw
it away so this is you know the single
greatest planetary pollution event in
the whole history of of the earth the
pollutant being oxygen yes
yeah it also made possible animals you
can't have large active animals without
an oxygenated atmosphere at least not
not in the sense that we know on earth
so that's a really big invention in this
huge intervention yes and it happened
once there's a few things that happen
once on earth and you know you're always
stuck with this problem is it once it
happened did it become so good so
quickly that it precluded the the same
thing happening ever again or are there
other reasons and we really have to look
at each one in turn and think
what's
why does it only happen once in this
case
it's really difficult
to split water it requires a lot of
power and that power you're effectively
separating charge across a membrane and
the way in which you do it if it doesn't
all rush back and and kind of cause an
explosion right at the site requires
really careful wiring um and that wiring
it can't be easy to get it right because
you know
the plants that we see around us they
have chloroplasts those chloroplasts
were cyanobacterial ones those
cyanobacteria are the only group of
bacteria that can do that type of
photosynthesis so there's plenty of
opportunity so not even many bacteria so
who who invented photosynthesis that the
cyanobacteria or their ancestors and
there's not many um no other bacteria
can do what's called oxygenic
photosynthesis lots of other bacteria
can split i mean you can take your
hydrogen from somewhere else you can
take it from hydrogen sulfide bubbling
out of a hydrothermal vent grab your two
hydrogens the sulfur is the waste now
um you can do it from iron you can take
electrons so the early oceans were
probably full of iron you can take an
electron from ferrous ion so iron two
plus and make it iron three plus which
now precipitates as rust
uh and you take a a proton from the
acidic early ocean stick it there now
you've got a hydrogen atom stick it onto
co2 you've just done the trick the
trouble is
you bury yourself in rusty iron and with
sulfur you can bury yourself in sulfur
one of the reasons oxygenic
photosynthesis is so much better is the
waste product is oxygen which just
bubbles away
that seems like extremely unlikely and
it's extremely essential for the
evolution of complex organisms
because of all the oxygen
yeah and that didn't accumulate quickly
either
so it's converting
what is it it's converting energy from
the sun
and the resource of water
into
the resource needed for animals
both resources needed for animals we
need to eat and we need to burn the food
and the we're eating plants um which are
getting their energy from the sun and
we're burning it with their waste
products which is the oxygen
so there's a lot of kind of circularity
in that but with with without an
oxygenated planet you couldn't really
have
um
predation
you
you don't you can have animals but you
can't really have animals that go around
and eat each other you can't have
ecosystems as we know them well let's
actually step back what about eukaryotic
versus prokaryotic cells prokaryotes
what how big
what are each of those and how big of an
invention is that
i personally think that's the single
biggest invention in the whole history
of life exciting
so what what are they can you explain
yeah so so so i mentioned bacteria and
archaea these are both prokaryotes
um they're basically small cells that
don't have a nucleus if you look at them
under a microscope you don't see much
going on if you look at them under a
super resolution microscope then they're
fantastically complex
in terms of their molecular machinery
they're amazing in terms of their
morphological appearance under a
microscope they're really small
and really simple the earliest life that
we can physically see on the planet are
stromatolites which are made by things
like cyanobacteria and then they're
large superstructures effectively
biofilms plated on top of each other
and and you end up with quite quite
large structures that you can see in the
fossil record
but they they don't
they never came up with animals they
never came up with plants they they hear
with multicellular things filamentous
cyanobacteria for example they're just
long you know strings of cells
but the origin of the eukaryotic cell
seems to have been what's called an
endosymbiosis so one cell gets inside
another cell
and i think that that transformed the
energetic possibilities of life so what
we end up with
is a kind of supercharged cell which can
have a much larger
nucleus with many more genes all
supported
if you think about you could think about
it as a multi-bacterial power without
the overhead so you've got you've got a
cell and it's got bacterial living in it
and those bacteria are providing it with
the energy currency it needs but each
bacterium has a genome of its own which
costs a fair amount of energy to
to to express to to kind of turn over
and convert into proteins and so on
what the mitochondria did which are
these
power packs in our own cells they were
bacteria once and they threw away
virtually all their genes they've only
got a few left
so mitochondria is like you said is the
bacteria that got inside a cell
and then throw away all this stuff it
doesn't need to survive inside the cell
and then kept what so what we end up
with so it kept always a handful of
genes
in our own case 37 genes
um but there's a there's a few protists
which are single cells things that have
got as many as 70 or 80 genes so it's
not always the same but it's always a
small number
um and
you can think of it as a paired down
power pack where the control unit is
really being has been kind of paired
down to almost nothing so you're putting
out the same power but the the
investment in in the overheads is really
paired down that means that you can
support a much larger nuclear genome so
we've gone up in the number of genes but
also the amount of power you have to
convert those genes into proteins
we've gone up about four-fold in the
number of genes but in terms of the the
size of genomes and your ability to to
make the building blocks make the
proteins we've gone up a hundred
thousand fold or more so it's huge step
change in the possibilities of evolution
uh and it is it's interesting then that
the only the only two occasions that
complex life has arisen on earth plants
and
animals fungi you could say are complex
as well but they don't form
such complex morphology as plants and
animals
start with a single cell they start with
an oocyte and a sperm fused together to
make a zygote so we start development
with a single cell and all the cells in
the organism have identical dna
and you switch off in the brain you
switch off these genes and you switch on
those genes and liver you switch off
those and you switch on a different set
and the standard evolution explanation
for that is that you've you you're
restricting conflict you don't have a
load of genetically different cells that
are all fighting each other um and so it
works the trouble with bacteria they
form these biofilms and they're all
genetically different and effectively
they're incapable of that level of
cooperation
they would get in a fight
okay so uh why is this such a difficult
invention
of getting this bacteria inside and
becoming an engine
which the mitochondria is why was that
why do you assign it such great
importance is it great importance in
terms of the difficulty of how it was to
achieve a great importance in terms of
the impact they had
on life both uh it had a huge impact on
life because
if if that had not happened you can be
certain that life on earth would be
bacterial only and that took a really
long time too it took two billion years
yeah and it hasn't happened since to the
best of our knowledge so it looks as if
it's genuinely difficult and if you
think about it then from from from just
an informational perspective you you
think bacteria
have got
they they structure their information
differently so a bacterial cell has a
small genome you might have 4 000 genes
in it but a single e coli cell has
access to about 30 000 genes
potentially it's got a kind of meta
genome where other e coli out there have
got different gene sets and they can
switch them around between themselves
and so you can generate a huge amount of
variation and you know they've got more
an e coli
meta genome is larger than the human
genome
we own 20 000 genes or something
so and they've had four billion years of
evolution to work out what can i do and
what can't i do with this metagenome and
the answer is you're stuck you're still
bacteria so they have explored
genetic sequence space
far more thoroughly than eukaryotes ever
did because they've had twice as long at
least and they've they've got much
larger populations and they never they
never got around this problem so why
can't they it seems as if you can't
solve it with information alone so
what's the what's what's the problem the
problem is structure
if if if cells if the very first cells
needed an electrical charge on their
membrane to grow
and in bacteria it's this is the outer
membrane that surrounds the cell which
is electrically charged
you try and scale that up and you've got
a fundamental design problem you've got
an engineering problem and there are
examples of it and what we see in all
these cases is what's known as extreme
polyploidy which is to say they have
tens of thousands of copies of their
complete genome
which is you know energetically hugely
expensive and
you end up with a large bacteria with
no further development
what you need is to incorporate these
electrically charged power pack units
inside with their control units intact
and for them not to conflict so much
with the host cell that it all goes
wrong perhaps it goes wrong more often
than not and then
you change the topology of the cell now
you don't necessarily have any more dna
than a giant bacterium with extreme
polyploidy but what you've got is
an asymmetry you now have a giant
nuclear genome we're surrounded by lots
of subsidiary energetic genomes that do
do all the and they're the control units
that are doing all the
all the control of energy generation
could this have been done gradually or
does it have to be done
the power pack has to be all intact and
ready to go and uh it works i mean it's
a kind of step changing the
possibilities of evolution but it
doesn't happen overnight it's going to
still require multiple multiple
generations so it could take you know it
could take millions of years
it could take shorter time this is
another thing i would like to put the
number of steps and try and work out
what's required at each step and we are
trying to do that with sex for example
you can't have a very large genome
unless you have sex at that point so
what are the changes to go from
bacterial recombination to eukaryotic
recombination
what what do you need to do why do we go
from passing around bits of dna as if
it's loose change to fusing cells
together lining up the chromosomes
recombining across the chromosomes and
then going through two rounds of cell
division to produce your gametes all
eukaryotes do it that way
so again you know
why switch what are the drivers here so
there's a lot of there's a lot of times
a lot of evolution but as soon as you've
got cells living inside another cell
what you've got is a is a new design you
you've got new potential that you didn't
have before so the
cell living inside another cell that
design
allows for
better storage of information
better use of energy
uh more delegation like a hierarchical
control of the whole thing
and then
and then somehow that leads to ability
to have multi-cell organisms i'm not
sure that you have hierarchical control
necessarily but you you've got a system
where you can you can have a much larger
information storage depot in the nucleus
you can have a much larger genome and
that allows multicellularity yes because
um it allows you
it's it's a funny thing you to to have a
to have a an animal where i have you
know 70 of my genes switched on in my
brain and i have different 50 switched
on in my liver or something you've got
to have all those genes in the egg cell
at the very beginning and you've got to
have a a program of development which
says okay you guys switch off those
genes and switch on those genes and you
guys you do that but all the genes are
there at the beginning that means you've
got to have a lot of genes in one cell
and you've got to be able to maintain
them and the problem with bacteria is
they don't get close to having enough
genes in one cell so they would if you
were to try and make a multicellular
organism from bacteria you'd bring
different types of bacteria together and
hope they'll cooperate and the reality
is they don't that's really really tough
to do yeah coming into we know they
don't because they're it doesn't exist
we have the data as far as we know i'm
sure there's a few like special ones and
they did off quickly
i'd love to know some of the most fun
things bacteria have done since
oh there's a few i mean they can do some
pretty funky things and this is big this
is broad brush stroke that i'm talking
about
yeah generally speaking uh so how was uh
so another you know fun invention
us humans seem to uh utilize it well but
you say it's also very important early
on is sex
so uh
what is sex uh just asking for a friend
and when was it invented and how hard
was it to invent just as you were saying
and why was it invented why
how hard was it and when
i have a phd student who's been working
on this and we've just asked a couple of
papers on sex yes yes what do you
publish these biology is it biology
genetics journals yeah this is actually
pnas which is
proceedings of the national academy
broad big big picture everyone's
interested in sex
of biologists is to make sex dull
yes yeah that's a beautiful way to put
it okay so when was it invented
uh it was invented with eukaryotes about
two billion years ago
um all eukaryotes
share the same basic mechanism that you
produce gametes the gametes fuse
together so a gamete is the egg cell and
the sperm they're not necessarily even
different in size or shape so the
simplest eukaryotes produce what are
called motile gametes they're all like
sperm and they all swim around they find
each other they fuse together they don't
have kind of much
much going on there beyond that and then
these are
haploid which is to say we all have two
copies of our genome and the the gametes
have only a single copy of the genome so
when they fuse together you now become
diploid again which is to say you now
have two copies of your genome and what
you do is you line them all up
um and then you and then you double
everything so now we have four copies of
the complete genome and then we criss
cross between all of these things so we
take a bit from here and stick it on
there and a bit from here and we stick
it on here that's recombination
um and and then we go through two rounds
of cell division so we divide in half so
now the two daughter cells have two
copies and we don't divide in half again
now we have some gametes each of which
has got a single copy of the genome
and that's the basic ground plan for
what's called meiosis and uh and
enhancing
that's basically sex
and it happens at the level of
single-celled organisms and it happens
pretty much the same way in plants and
pretty much the same way in animals and
so on and it's not found in any bacteria
they switch things around using the same
machinery and they take up a bit of dna
from the environment they take out this
bit and stick in that bit and it's the
same molecular machinery they're using
to do it so what about the kind of you
said find each other this kind of
imperative
yeah find each other
what is that
like is that well you've got a few cells
together
so the bottom the bottom line on all of
this is is is bacteria i mean it's kind
of simple uh when when you when you've
figured it out and figuring it out this
is not me this is my phd student marco
kolnagi um
and uh and
in effect if you if you're doing lateral
you're an e coli cell you've got 4 000
genes you want to scale up to a
eukaryotic size and i want to have 20
000 genes um and i'm and i need to
maintain my genome so it doesn't get
shot to pieces by mutations and i'm
going to do it by lateral gene transfer
so
i know i've got a mutation in a gene i
don't know which gene it is because i'm
not sentient but i know i can't grow i
know all my regulation systems are
saying
something wrong here something wrong
pick up some dna pick up a bit of dna
from the environment
if you've got a small genome the chances
of you picking up the right bit of dna
from the environment is much higher than
if you've got a genome of 20 000 genes
to do that you've effectively got to be
picking up dna all the time all day long
and nothing else and you're still going
to get the wrong dna you've got to pick
up large chunks and in the end you've
got to align them you're forced
into
to kind of phrase um
so yeah
uh so it's it's so there is a kind of uh
um incentive
uh if you want to have a large genome
you've got to prevent it mutating to
nothing
that will happen with bacteria there's
another reason why bacteria can't have a
large genome but as soon as you give
them the power path as soon as you give
your carotid cells the power pack that
allows them to increase the size of
their genome then you face the pressure
that you've got to maintain its quality
you've got to stop it just mutating away
what about sexual selection so the the
finding
uh like uh i don't like this one i don't
like this one this one seems all right
like what's the the
the is is it at which point does it
become less random it's hard to know
because your courier's just kind of
floated around i'm just kind of have
yeah there's everything that's their
section
in single cell do you characterize the
probably is it's just that i don't know
very much about it by the time you don't
hang out with the acquisitions well i do
all the time but you know but they can't
communicate with them yet yeah
peacock or something yes um
the kind of standardize is not quite
what i work on but the standard answer
uh is that
it's female mate choice she is looking
for good genes
um and and if you can have a tail that's
like this
and and still survive still be alive not
actually being taken down by the nearest
predator then you must have got pretty
good genes because despite this handicap
you're able to survive so so those are
like human interpretable things like
with a peacock but i wonder i'm sure
echoes of the same thing
are there with more primitive
organisms
basically your pr like uh how you
advertise yourself that you're worthy
yeah of uh absolutely so one big
advertisement is the fact that you
survived it all
let me give you one one beautiful
example uh of an algal bloom
and this can be this can be a
cyanobacteria it can be in bacteria
so so if if suddenly you you know you
pump nitrate or phosphate or something
into the ocean and everything goes green
you end up with all this
uh
algae growing there
um
a viral infection or something like that
can kill the entire bloom overnight
and it's not that the virus takes out
everything overnight it's that most of
the cells in that bloom kill themselves
before the virus can get onto them and
it's through a form of cell death called
programmed cell death and we we do the
same thing this is how we have the
different you know the gaps between our
fingers and so on it's how we craft
synapses in the brain
um it you know is fundamental again to
to
to multicellular life they have the same
machinery in these in these algal blooms
how do they know who dies the answer is
they will often put out a toxin
and that toxin
is a kind of a challenge to you either
you can cope with the toxin or you can't
if you can cope with it you form a spore
and you will go on to become the next
generation you you you form a kind of a
resistance spore you sink down a little
bit you get out of the way you're out of
the out out of you can't be attacked by
a virus if you're a spore at least not
so easily whereas if you can't deal with
that toxin you pull the plug and you you
you you trigger your death apparatus and
you kill yourself because it's truly
life and death
yeah
so it's really it's a challenge and this
is a bit like sexual selection it's not
so they're all pretty much genetically
identical
but they've had different life histories
so have you had a you know a tough day
did you did you happen to get infected
by this virus or did you run out of iron
or did you get a bit too much sun
whatever it may be if this extra stress
of the toxin just pushes you over the
edge then you have this binary choice
either you're the next generation or you
kill yourself now using this same
machinery it's also actually exactly the
way i approach dating but that's
probably why i'm single okay
uh what about if we can step back dna
just mechanism of storing information
rna dna yeah how big of an invention was
that that seems to be you that seems to
be fundamental to
like
something
deep within what life is is the ability
as you said to kind of store and
propagate information but then you also
kind of infer that with your and your
students work that
there's a deep connection between the
chemistry and the ability
uh to have this kind of genetic
information so how big of an invention
is is it to have
a nice representation a nice hard drive
for info to pass on huge i suspect uh i
mean but
when i was talking about the code you
see the code in rna as well and rna
almost certainly came first
um and there's been an idea going back
decades called the rna world because rna
in theory can copy itself and can
catalyze reactions so it kind of cuts
out this chicken and egg loop so dna
it's possible it's not that special so
our rna rna is the thing that does the
work really
and the code lies in rna the code lies
in the interactions between rna and
amino acids and it still is there today
in the ribosome for example which is
just kind of a giant ribozyme which is
to say it's an enzyme that's made of rna
so
getting to rna i suspect is probably not
that hard
but getting from rna
how do you you know there's multiple
different types of rna now how do how do
how do you distinguish this is something
where actively thinking about how do you
distinguish between you know a random
population of rnas some of them go on to
become
messenger rna that this is the the
transcript of the code of the gene that
you you want to make some of them become
transfer rna which is which is the kind
of the unit that holds the amino acid
that's going to be polynomial
polymerized some of them become
ribosomal rna which is the machine which
is joining them all up together
how do they
discriminate themselves and
you know some kind of phase transition
going on there what's i don't know it's
a difficult question
and we're now
in the region of biology where
information is coming in but the thing
about rna is very very good at what it
does but the largest genomes supported
by rna of rna viruses like hiv for
example they're pretty small
and and so there's a limit to how
complex life could be
unless you come up with dna which
chemically is a really small change but
how easy it is to make that change
i don't really know as soon as you've
got dna then you've got an amazingly
stable molecule for information storage
um and you can do absolutely anything
but how likely that transition from rna
to dna was i don't know either
how much possibility is there for
variety
in ways to store information because it
seems to be very specific
characteristics about
the the programming language of dna yeah
there's a lot of work going on what's
called xenodna or
rna can we replace the the bases
themselves the the letters if you like
in in in rna or dna can we replace the
backbone can we replace for example
phosphate with arsenate
can we replace the sugar ribose or
deoxyribose with a different sugar and
the answer is yes you can
um
within limits
there's not an infinite space there
arsenate doesn't really work if the
bonds are not as strong as phosphate
it's probably quite hard to replace
phosphate um
it's possible to do it the question to
me is
why is it this way
is it because there was some form of
selection that this is better than the
other forms and there were lots of
competing forms of information storage
early on and this one was the one that
worked out or was it kind of channeled
that way that these are the molecules
that you're dealing with
um and and they work uh and i'm
increasingly thinking it's that way that
we're channeled towards ribose phosphate
and and
and the bases that are used but there
are you know 200 different letters
kicking around out there that could have
been used it's such an interesting
question if you look at in the
programming world in computer science
there's a programming language called
javascript yeah which was uh written
super quickly it's a giant mess but it
took over the world
and it was sounds very biological it was
it was kind of a running joke that like
um
like surely this can't be
the it's a terrible programming language
it's a giant mess it's full of
bugs it's so easy to write really crappy
code but it took over all of front-end
development in the web browser
if you have any kind of dynamic
interactive website it has it's usually
running javascript
and it's now taking over much of the
backend which is like the serious heavy
duty computational stuff and it's become
super fast with the different
compilation engines
um that are running it so it's like it
really took over the world it's very
possible that this
initially crappy
uh derided language actually takes
everything over and then the question is
did human civilization always strive
towards javascript
or was javascript just the first
programming language that ran on the
browser and still sticky the first the
first is the sticky one and so it wins
over anything else because it was first
and we i don't think that's answerable
right but it's good to
ask that i suppose in the lab
you can't you can't
run it with programming languages but in
biology you can probably
do some kind of
um
small scale evolutionary
tests to try to infer which which is
which yeah i mean in a way we've we've
got the hardware and the software here
and and the the hardware is maybe the
the dna and the rna itself and then the
software perhaps is more about the code
is did the code have to be this way
could it have been a different way yeah
people talk about the optimization of
the code and there's some suggestion for
that uh i think it's weak actually
but you could imagine you could come out
with a million different codes and and
this would be one of the best ones
um
well we don't know this well i mean
people have tried to model it based on
the effect that mutations would have
um so no you're right we don't know
because that's the thing that's a single
assumption that a mutation is is what's
being selected on there and there's
other possibilities too i mean there
does seem to be a resilience and a
redundancy to the whole thing it's hard
to mess up
in in the way you mess it up
often
is likely to produce interesting results
so it's um are you talking about
javascript or the genetic code now
yeah well i mean it's almost you know
biology is underpinned by this kind of
mess as well you look at the human
genome and it's full of stuff that is
really either broken or dysfunctional or
was a virus once whatever it may be and
somehow it works and maybe we need a lot
of this mess you know we know that some
functional genes are taken from this
mess
so what about you mentioned
predatory behavior
yeah we talked about sex what about
violence predator and prey dynamics
how uh when was that invented
and uh
poetic and biological ways of putting it
like what how do you describe a
predator-prey relationship is it a
beautiful dance or is it a
violent atrocity
well i guess it's both isn't it i mean
when does it start it starts in bacteria
you see these amazing predators
delivibrio is one that lynne margulis
used to talk about a lot um it's it's
got a kind of a drill piece that drills
through the wall and the membrane of the
bacterium and then it effectively eats
the bacterium from just inside the
periplasmic space and makes copies of
itself that way so that's straight
predation there are predators among
bacteria
so predation in that sorry to interrupt
means
you murder somebody and
use their body as a resource
in some way
yeah but it's not parasitic
in that you need them to be still alive
no no i mean predation is you kill them
really murder parasite is so you kind of
live on them okay so but it seems the
predator is really popular
uh um
so what we see if we go back
560 570 million years
before the cambrian explosion there is
um
what's known as the ediacaran fauna or
sometimes they call vendo bions which is
a lovely name
uh and and it's not obvious that they're
animals at all
uh they're stalked things they often
have fronds that look a lot like leaves
with kind of fractal branching patterns
on them um
and
the thing is they've they're found
sometimes
geologists can figure out the
environment that they were in and say
this is more than 200 meters deep
because there's no sign of any waves
there's no you know
no storm damage down here this kind of
thing
they were more than 200 meters deep so
they're definitely not photosynthetic
these are animals
and they're they're filter feeders and
we know things you know sponges and
corals and things are filter-feeding
animals they're stuck to the spot uh and
little bits of carbon that come their
way they they filter it out and that's
what they're eating
um so no predation involved in this
beyond stuff just dies anyway and it
feels like a very gentle rather
beautiful rather limited world you might
say
there's not a lot going on there
and
something changes
oxygen definitely changes during this
period other things may have changed as
well but the next thing you really see
in the fossil record is the cambrian
explosion
and what do we see there
we're now seeing animals that we would
recognize they've got eyes they've got
claws they've got shells they're you
know they're plainly killing things or
running away
um and and hiding um and and so we've
gone from a rather gentle but limited
world to a rather vicious unpleasant
world that we recognize
and which leads to
kind of arms races evolutionary arms
races
which again is something that when we
think about a nuclear arms race we think
jesus we don't want to go there it's not
done anybody any good
in some ways maybe we maybe it does do
good i don't want to make an argument
for nuclear arms but but predation
as a as a mechanism
forces organisms to adapt to change to
be better to escape to to or to kill um
if you need to eat then you've got to
eat and you know a cheetah is not going
to run at that speed unless it's
unless it has to because the the zebra
is capable of escaping so it leads to
to much greater feats of evolution than
would ever have been possible without it
and in the end to a much more beautiful
world
and so
it's not all bad
by any means the the but the thing is
you can't have this if you don't have an
oxygenated planet because if you it's
all in the end it's about how much
energy can you extract from the food you
eat
and if you don't have an oxygenated
planet you can get about 10
out not much more than that um and if
you've got an oxygenated planet you can
get about 40 out and that means you can
have instead of having one or two trophy
levels
you can have five or six trophies levels
and that means things can eat things
that eat other things and so on and and
you've gone to a level of ecological
complexity which is completely
impossible in the absence of oxygen
this reminds me of the hunter s thompson
quote that for every moment of triumph
for every instance of beauty
many souls must be trampled
i their the history of life on earth
unfortunately is
that of violence
just the trillions and trillions of
multi-cell organisms that were murdered
in the in this struggle it's a sorry
statement but yes it's basically true
and that's somehow
is a catalyst
from an evolutionary perspective for
creativity for
creating more and more complex organisms
that are better and better at survival i
mean survival of the fittest if you just
go back to that old phrase means death
of the weakest um now what's fit what's
weak these are terms that don't have
much intrinsic meaning but the thing is
evolution only happens because of death
one way to die is the the constraints
the scarcity of the resources in the
environment
but that seems to be not nearly as good
of a mechanisms
mechanism for death
than other creatures
roaming about in the environment when i
say environment i mean like the static
environment but then there's the dynamic
environment of
bigger things trying to eat you and use
you for your energy
it forces you to come up with a with a
solution to your specific problem
that you that is inventive and is new
and hasn't been done before and so it
forces i mean literally uh change
literally evolution on on populations
they have to become different and it's
interesting that humans have channeled
that
into more
i mean i guess what humans are doing is
they're inventing
more productive and safe ways of doing
that you know this whole idea of
morality and all those kinds of things
i think they ultimately lead
to competition
versus violence because i think
violence can have a
cold
brutal inefficient aspect to it but if
you channel that into more
controlled competition
in the space of ideas
in the space of approaches to life maybe
you can
um
be even more productive than evolution
is because evolution is very wasteful
like the amount of murder required to
really test the good idea yeah
genetically speaking is just a lot yeah
many many many generations morally we
cannot
base society on the way that evolution
works that's that's not mentioned right
but actually in some respects we do
which is to say this is how science
works we have competing hypotheses that
have to get better otherwise they die
it's the way that society works we you
know in in in ancient greece we had we
had the the the athens and sparta and
city-states and then we had the
renaissance and and nation-states and we
you know universities compete with each
other yes tremendous amounts of
companies competing with each other all
the time it it drives innovation um
and if we want to do it without all the
death that we see in nature then we have
to have some kind of societal level
control that says well hit the some
limits guys and these are what the
limits are going to be and society as a
whole has to say right we want to limit
the amount of death here so you can't do
this and you can't do that and you know
who makes up these rules and how do we
know it's it's a tough thing but it's
basically trying to find a moral basis
for avoiding the death of evolution and
natural selection and keeping the the
the innovation and the and the richness
of it
i forgot who said it but
that murder is illegal probably current
finding it murder is illegal except when
it's done to the sound of trumpets and
at a large scale
so we still have wars
but we are struggling with this idea
that murder is a bad thing
it's so interesting how we're channeling
the best
of the evolutionary imperative
and trying to um get rid of the stuff
that's not productive
trying to almost accelerate evolution
the same kind of
thing that um
uh makes evolution creative we're trying
to use that i think we naturally do it i
mean i don't think we can help ourselves
do it and you know capitalism capitalism
as a form is is basically about
competition and and differential rewards
but
we society and you know we have a
i keep using this world moral obligation
but you know we cannot operate as a
society if we go that way it's
interesting that
we've had problems achieving balance so
for example in the in the financial
crash in 2009
do you let banks go to the wall or not
this kind of question in evolution
certainly you let them go to the wall
and in that sense you don't need the
regulation because they just die
whereas if we
as a society think about what's required
for society as a whole then you don't
necessarily let them go to the wall
uh in which case you then have to impose
some kind of regulation that the bankers
themselves will in an evolutionary
manner exploit
yeah it's we've been struggling with
this kind of idea of capitalism
the the the cold brutality of capitalism
that seems to create so much
beautiful things in this world
and then the
the ideals of communism that seem to
create so much brutal destruction in
history and we struggle with ideas
of well maybe we didn't do it right how
can we do things better and then the
ideas are the things we're playing with
as opposed to people if a phd student
has a bad idea we don't shoot the phds
we just criticize their idea and i hope
they improve you have a very humane lab
yeah yeah i don't know how you guys do
it you know
the way i run things uh it's always life
and death okay so it is interesting
about humans that there is an inner
sense of morality
which begs the question of
how did homo sapiens
evolve if we think about the invention
of
early invention of sex and early
invention of predation
what was the thing invented
to make humans
what would you say i mean i suppose a
couple of things i'd say number one is
you don't have to wind the clock back
very far
five six million years or so and and and
and let it run forwards again and the
chances of
humans as we know them is not
necessarily that high
and you know imagine
as an alien you find planet earth and
it's got everything apart from humans on
it it's an amazing wonderful marvelous
planet but nothing that we would
recognize as
extremely intelligent life and
space-faring civilization so when we
think about aliens we we we're kind of
after something like ourselves or after
a space-faring civilization we're not
after you know
zebras and giraffes and lions and things
amazing though they are
but the
the additional kind of evolutionary
steps to go from
large complex mammals monkeys let's say
to
to humans
doesn't strike me as that longer a
distance it's all about the brain and
where's the where's the brain and
morality coming from it seems to me
to be all about groups human groups and
interactions between groups the
collective intelligence of it the yes
the interactions really and there's some
there's a guy at ucl uh called mark
thomas who's done a lot of really
beautiful work i think on on this kind
of question so i talk to him every now
and then so my views are influenced by
him
um
but a lot seems to depend on population
density
that the more interactions you have
going on between different groups the
more transfer
of information if you like between
groups
of people moving from one group to
another group almost like lateral gene
transfer in bacteria
the more expertise you're able to
develop and maintain
the more
culturally complex your society can
become and groups that have become
detached
like on easter island for example very
often degenerate in terms of the
complexity of their civilization is that
true for complex organisms in general
population density is often productive
really matters but in human terms
um
i don't know what the actual factors
were that were driving a a large brain
but you know you can you can talk about
fire you can talk about tool use you can
talk about language and none of them
seem to correlate especially well with
the actual known trajectory of human
evolution in terms of
cave art and these kind of things that
that seems to work much better just with
with population density and number of
interactions between different groups
all of which is really
about
human interactions human human
interactions and the complexity of those
but
population density is the thing that
increases the number of interactions but
then there must have been inventions
uh forced by that
number of interactions that actually led
to humans so like richard wrangham
talks about that
it's basically the beta males had to
beat up the alpha male so that's what
collaboration looks like is they when
you're living together they don't like
this
the
our early ancestors
don't like the dictatorial aspect of a
single individual at the top of a tribe
so they uh they they learn to
collaborate how to
uh basically create a democracy uh of
sorts a democracy that prevents
minimizes or lessens the amount of
violence which essentially
gives strength to the tribe and make the
war
between tribes
uh versus the dictator i mean i think
one of the what most wonderful things
about humans is we're all of those
things i mean we are deeply social as a
species and we're also deeply selfish
and it seems to me the conflict between
capitalism and communism it's really
just two aspects of human nature both of
which are both we have both uh and we
have a constant kind of vying between
the two sides we really do care about
other people beyond our families beyond
our immediate people we care about
society and the society that we live in
and and you could say that's a you know
a drawing towards socialism or communism
on the other side we really do care
about ourselves we really do care about
our families about working for something
that we gain from and that's the
capitalist side of it they're both
really deeply ingrained in human nature
in terms of violence um and
and interactions between groups yes all
this dynamic of if you're interacting
between groups you can be certain that
they're going to be burning each other
and all kinds of interact physical
violent interactions as well which will
drive
the kind of cleverness of how do you
resist this let's build a tower let's
you know what are we going to do to to
to to prevent being overrun by those
marauding gangs from over there
um and you look you look outside humans
and you look at chimps and bonnibos and
so on and they're very very different
structures to society chimps tend to
have an aggressive alpha male type
structure and bonobos are you know they
they there's basically a female society
where the males are predominantly
excluded and only brought in at the
behest of the female
we have a lot in common with both
both of those groups and there's again
tension there yeah and uh probably
chimps more violence with bonobos
probably more sex
that's another tension
[Laughter]
how serious do i do do we want to be how
much fun we want to be uh asking for a
friend again
what do you think happened to
neanderthals what did we
cheeky humans do to the neanderthals
homo sapiens do you think we murdered
them was it
that how do we murder them how do we
out-compete them
um
do we i made them i don't know i mean i
i think there's unequivocal evidence
that we mated with them yeah we always
try to meet with everything yes pretty
much
there's some interesting the first
sequences that came along were in
mitochondrial dna
and that was back to about 2002 or
thereabouts
what was found was that neanderthal
mitochondrial dna was very different to
human mitochondria that's so interesting
you could do a clock on it and it said
the divergent state was about 600 000
years ago or something like that so not
so long ago
um and then the first full genomes were
secrets maybe 10 years after that
and they showed plenty of signs of
mating between so so the mitochondrial
dna effectively says no mating
and the the nuclear
genes say yeah lots of mating
um but we don't know is that possible so
can you explain the difference between
mitochondrial cell yes and new uh
nucleus i've talked before about the
mitochondria which are the power packs
in cells these are the paired down
control units is that is their dna
so
it's passed on by the mother only
and
in the egg cell we might have half a
million copies of mitochondrial dna
there's only 37 genes left
and and they do a
it's basically the control unit of
energy production that's what is that's
what it's doing it's a basic old-school
machine that does and it's got genes
that were considered to be effectively
trivial because they did they did a a
very narrowly defined job but they're
not trivial in the sense that that
narrowly defined job is about
everything is being alive yeah um so
so they're much easier to sequence
you've got many more copies of these
things and you can sequence them very
quickly
um but the problem is because they go
down only the maternal line from mother
to daughter your mitochondrial dna and
mine is going nowhere doesn't matter any
kids we have they get their mother's
mitochondrial dna
um except in very very rare and strange
circumstances
um and so it tells a different story and
it's not a story which is easy to
reconcile always
um and and what it seems to suggest to
my mind at least is that there was one
way
uh traffic of genes probably going from
humans into neanderthals rather than the
other way around
why did the neanderthals disappear i i
don't know i mean i i suspect that they
were
i suspect they were probably less
violent less clever
uh less populous
less
willing to fight i i don't know i mean i
i think it drove them to extinction at
the margins of europe
and it's interesting how much if we ran
earth over and over again
how many of these branches of
intelligent beings
that have
figured out some kind of
how to leverage collective intelligence
which ones of them emerge which ones of
them succeed is it the more violent ones
is it um
uh the more isolated one you know like
what dynamics results in more
productivity and we i suppose we'll
never know it's
the more complex the organism the harder
it is to run the experiment in the lab
yes
and in some respects maybe it's best if
we don't know
yeah the truth might be very painful
what about if we actually step back
a couple of interesting things that we
humans do
one is object manipulation and
movement
and of course movement was something
that was done
that was another big invention being
able to move around the environment
and the other one is
this sensory mechanism how we sense the
environment one of the coolest high
definition ones is vision
uh how big are those inventions in the
history of
life on earth
vision movement uh i mean again
extremely important going back to the
origin of animals the cambrian explosion
where suddenly you're seeing eyes
in the fossil record and you can it's
not necessarily again lots of people
historically have said what use is half
an eye and and
you know you can go in a series of steps
uh from a a light sensitive spot on a
flat
piece of tissue
to an eyeball with a lens and so on um
if you assume no more than then i i
don't remember this this was a specific
model that i have in mind but it was you
know
one percent change or half a percent
change for each generation how long
would it take to evolve and high as we
know it and the answer is half a million
years
um it doesn't have to take long that's
not how evolution works that's not a
that's not an answer to the question it
just shows you can reconstruct the steps
and you can work out roughly how it can
work
so it's not that big a deal to evolve an
eye
but once you have one then there's
nowhere to hide and again we're back to
predator prey relationships where back
to all the benefits that being able to
see brings you and if you think you know
philosophically what bats are doing with
ecolocation and so on
i have no idea but i suspect that they
form an image of the world in pretty
much the same way that we do it's just a
matter of mental reconstruction so i
suppose the other thing about sight
there are single celled
organisms that have got a lens
and a a retina and a and a cornea and so
on basically they've got a camera type
eye in a single cell they don't have a
brain
um
what they understand about their world
is impossible to say but but they're
capable of coming up with with the same
structures to do so so i suppose then
is that once you've got things like eyes
then you have a big driving pressure on
the central nervous system to figure out
what it all means and we come around to
your other point about manipulation
sensory input and so on about you now
now you
you you you have a huge requirement to
understand what your environment is and
what it means and how it reacts and how
you should run away and where you should
stay put
actually on that point let me i don't
know if you know the work of donald
hoffman
who talks about
who uses the argument
um
the mechanism of evolution to say that
there's not necessarily a
strong evolutionary
value
to seeing the world as it is
so objective reality that our perception
actually
is very different from what's
objectively real
we're living inside an illusion and
we're basically the entire
uh the entire set of species on earth i
think i i guess are competing in a space
that's an illusion that's distinct from
this far away from physical reality as
it is as defined by physics i'm not sure
it's an illusion so much as a bubble i
mean we we have a sensory input which is
a fraction of what we could have a
sensory input on um and we interpret it
in terms of what's useful for us to know
to stay alive so yes it's an illusion in
that sense but
the tree is physically there and if you
walk into that tree you you know that
there is it's not purely a delusion
there's some physical reality to it so
it's a it's a uh
sensory slice into reality as it is but
because it's just a slice you're missing
a big picture but he says that that
slice doesn't necessarily need to be a
slice
it could be a complete fabrication
that's just consistent amongst the
species which is an interesting or at
least it's a humbling
realization that our perception
is limited and our cognitive abilities
are limited
and
at least to me
it's argument from evolution i don't
know
how much how how strong that is as an
argument
but
i do think that life can exist
in the mind
yes in the same way that you can do a
virtual reality video game and you can
have a vibrant life inside that place
and that place is not real in some sense
but you could still have a vibe all the
same forces of evolution all the same
competition the dynamics of uh between
humans you can have
but i don't know
if um
i don't know if there's evidence for
that being the thing that happened on
earth it seems that earth i think in
either environment i wouldn't deny that
you could have exactly the world that
you talk about and it would be very
difficult to uh you know the the idea um
in in matrix movies and so on that the
whole world is completely
a construction um
and we're fundamentally deluded it's
it's difficult to say that's impossible
or couldn't happen or
and certainly we construct in our minds
what the outside world is but we do it
on input and that input
i i would hesitate to say it's not real
um because it's precisely how we do
understand the world we you know we have
eyes but if you keep someone in
apparently this kind of thing happens
someone kept in a dark room for five
years or something like that and they
never see properly again because they've
the the the neural wiring that underpins
how we interpret vision never developed
you know you need when you watch a child
develop it walks right it walks into a
table it bangs its head on the table and
it hurts uh and
now you've got two inputs you've got one
pane from this sharp edge and number two
you probably you've touched it and
realized it's there it's a sharp edge
and you've got the visual input and you
put the three things together and think
i don't want to walk into a table again
so you're learning and and it's a
limited reality but it's a true reality
and if you don't learn that properly
then you will get eaten you will get hit
by a bus you will not survive
uh and same if you if you're in in in
some kind of uh
let's say computer construction of
reality i'm not in my ground here but if
if you construct the laws that this is
what reality is inside in inside this
then you play by those laws yeah well i
mean as long as the laws are consistent
so just like you said in the lab
the interesting thing about the
simulation question yes it's hard to
know if we're living inside a simulation
but also yes it's possible to do these
kinds of experiments in the lab now
more and more to me the interesting
question is
how
realistic does a virtual reality game
need to be for us to not be able to tell
the difference
a more interesting question to me is
how realistic
or
interesting does the virtual reality
world need to be in order for us to want
to stay there forever or much longer
than
physical reality prefer that place and
also prefer it not as we prefer
uh hard drugs but prefer in a deep
meaningful way in the way we
we enjoy
i mean i suppose the issue with the
matrix i i imagine that it's possible to
to delude the mind sufficiently that you
genuinely in that way do think that you
are
interacting with the real world when in
fact the whole thing is a simulation
how good does the simulation need to be
to be able to do that well it needs to
convince you that all your sensory input
is correct and accurate and and and
joins up and makes sense now that
sensory input is not something that
we're born with we're born with a sense
of touch we're born with eyes and so but
we don't know how to use them we don't
know what to make of them
we go around we bump into trees we cry a
lot we're in pain a lot we you know
we're we're basically booting up the
system so that it it can make head a
tail of the sensory input that it's
getting and that sensory input's not
just a one-way flux of things it's also
you have to walk into things you have to
hear things you have to put it together
now if you've got just babies
in in the matrix who are slotted into
this i don't think they have that kind
of sensory input i don't think they
would have any way to make sense of new
york
uh as a world that they're part of
the brain is just not developed in that
way so i can't make sense of new york in
this physical reality either but yeah i
mean but you said pain and walking into
things well you can create a pain signal
and as long as it's consistent
that certain things result in pain you
could start to construct a reality
there's some maybe maybe you disagree
with this but i think we are born
almost with a desire to be convinced by
our reality
like a
desire to make sense of our reality oh
i'm sure we are yes okay so there's an
imperative so whatever that reality is
given to us like the table hurts fire's
hot yeah i think
we want to be deluded
in a sense that we want to make a simple
like einstein simple theory of the thing
around us we want that simplicity and so
um maybe
the hunger for the simplicity is the
thing that could be used to construct a
pretty dumb simulation
that that tricks us so maybe tricking
humans doesn't require building a
universe
no i i don't i mean i this is not what i
work on so i don't know how close to it
we are anyone working but i i agree with
you but yeah i'm not sure that it's
a morally justifiable thing to do but
it's it's
is it possible in principle
um i think it'll be very difficult
but i don't see why in principle it
wouldn't be possible and i agree with
you that it's it's um that we try to
understand the world we try to integrate
the sensory inputs that we have and we
try to come up with a hypothesis that
explains what's going on
i think though
that we have
huge input from
the social context that we're in we
don't do it by ourselves we don't kind
of blunder around in a universe by
ourself and understand the whole thing
we're told by the people around us uh
what things are and what they do and
that you know language is coming in here
and so on so
it would have to be an extremely
impressive simulation to simulate all of
that
yeah simulate all of that including the
social construct this the the thing the
the spread of ideas and the the the
exchange of ideas i don't know and but
those questions are really important to
understand as we
become more and more digital creatures
it seems like the next step of evolution
is us becoming
partial all the same mechanisms we've
talked about
are becoming more and more plugged in
into the machine
we're becoming cyborgs
and there's an interesting interplay
between wires and biology
um
you know zeros and ones and the
biological systems and i don't think
you can just
i don't think we'll have the luxury to
see humans as disjoint from the
technology we've created for much longer
we are in organisms that's um
yeah
i mean i
agree with you
but
we come really with this to
consciousness yes and is there a
distinction there because what you're
saying the natural end point says we are
indistinguishable that if you are
capable of building
a
an ai
which is sufficiently close and similar
that we merge with it then then
to all intents and purposes that ai is
conscious as we know it
um
and i don't
i don't have a strong view but i have a
view
um
and i i wrote about it in the epilogue
to my last book because 10
years ago i i
wrote a chapter in in a book called life
ascending about consciousness
and the subtitle of life ascending was
was the ten great inventions of
evolution and i couldn't possibly write
a book with a subtitle like that that
did not include consciousness
and specifically consciousness uh
as one of the great inventions
and it was in part because i was just
curious to know more and i read more for
that chapter i never worked on it but
i've always how can anyone not be
interested in the question
um and i was left with the feeling that
hey nobody knows and b there are two
main
schools of thought out there
with a big kind of a skew in
distribution one of them says oh it's a
property of matter there's an unknown
law of physics
pan psychism everything is conscious the
sun is conscious it's just a matter or a
rock is conscious it's just a matter of
how much
and i find that very unpersuasive um i
can't say that it's wrong it's just that
i think we somehow can tell the
difference between something that's
living and something that's not
and then the other the other end is it's
a it's an emergent property of a very
complex central nervous system
um and
i am
i never quite understand what people
mean by words like emergence i mean
there are genuine examples but i think
we very often tend to
um use it to
to plaster over uh ignorance
as a biochemist the question for me then
was okay it's a it's a concoction of a
central nervous system
a depolarizing neuron gives rise to a
feeling to a feeling of pain or to a
feeling of love
or
anger or whatever it may be
so what is then a feeling in biophysical
terms in the central nervous system
which bit of the wiring gives rise to
and i i've never seen anyone answer that
question you know
in a way that makes sense to me and
that's an important question to answer
i think if we want to understand
consciousness that's the only question
to answer because i you know i certainly
a an ai is capable of out thinking and
it's only a matter of time maybe it's
already happened in terms of just
information processing and computational
skill i don't think we have any problem
in designing
a mind which is at least the equal of
the human mind
but in terms of what we value the most
as humans which is to say our feelings
our emotions our
our
sense of what the world is in a in a
very personal way
that i think means as much or more to
people than their information processing
and that's where i
don't think that ai necessarily will
become conscious because
i think it's the property of life well
let's talk about it more you're an
incredible writer one of my favorite
writers so let me read
from your latest book transformers what
you write about consciousness
i think therefore i am said descartes
is one of the most celebrated lines ever
written
but what am i exactly
and artificial intelligence can think
too by definition and therefore is
yet few of us could agree whether ai is
capable in principle of anything
resembling human emotions of love or
hate
fear and joy
of spiritual yearnings
for oneness or oblivion or corporeal
pangs of thirst and hunger
the problem is we don't know what
emotions are as you were saying
what is the feeling in physical terms
how does a discharging neuron give rise
to a feeling of anything at all
this is the heart problem of
consciousness
the seeming duality of mind and matter
the physical makeup of our innermost
self
we can understand in principle how an
extremely sophisticated parallel
processing system could be capable of
wonderous feasts of intelligence but
we can't answer in principle whether
such a supreme intelligence would
experience joy or melancholy what is the
quantum of solace
i
speaking to the question of emergence
you know there's just technical um
uh
there's a there's an excellent paper on
this uh recently about
the um this kind of face transition
emergence of performance in neural
networks on the
problem of nlp natural language
processing so language models there
seems to be
this question of size
at some point
there is a phase transition as you grow
the size of the neural network so the
question is
this is sort of somewhat of a technical
question that you can philosophize over
the technical question is is there a
size of a neural network that starts to
be able to form
the kind of representations that can
capture a language and therefore be able
to
um not just language but linguistically
capture knowledge that's sufficient to
solve a lot of problems
in language like be able to have a
conversation and there seems to be not a
gradual increase but a face transition
and we in the they're trying to
construct the science of where that is
like what is the good size of a neural
network and why does such a face
transition happen anyway that that sort
of points to emergence that there
there could be
stages where
a thing goes from being oh you're
you're very intelligent toaster
to a toaster
that's feeling sad today and turns away
and looks out
um out the window
sighing having an existential crisis
thinking you're marvin the paranoid
android is that well no marvin is
simplistic because marvin is just cranky
yes
uh it's so easily programmed yeah easily
programmed non-stop existential crisis
you're almost basically uh what is notes
from underground but dusty like just
just constantly complaining about life
no they're
capturing the full
rollercoaster of human emotion the
excitement the bliss the connection
um the empathy and all that kind of
stuff and then the selfishness
the the anger
the the depression all that kind of
stuff the capturing all of that
and be able to experience it deeply like
it's the most important
thing you could possibly experience
today the highest highs the lowest lows
this is it my life will be over this
i cannot possibly go on that feeling and
then like after a nap
you're feeling amazing
that might be something that emerges so
why would a nap
make
an ai being feel better
the
first of all we don't know that for a
human either right but we do know that
that's actually true for many people
much of the time you may be depressed
when you do in fact feel better so
oh you are actually asking the technical
question there is there uh so that's a
very there's a biological answer to that
and so the question is whether ai needs
to have the same kind of attachment to
its body and bodily function and
preservation
of the brain's successful function
of
self-preservation essentially in some
deep biological sense
i mean i to my mind it comes back round
to the problem we were talking about
before about simulations and sensory
input and learning what all of this
stuff means
and life and death
um
that that biology unlike society has a
death penalty over everything and
natural selection works on that death
penalty that if you make this
decision wrongly
you die
and
the next generation is represented by
beings that
made a slightly different decision
on balance
um
and that is something that's
intrinsically
difficult to simulate in all this
richness i i would say
um
so so what is
death in all its richness
yes the our relationship with death
or or or the whole of it so which when
you say richness of course
there's a lot in that yeah which is hard
to simulate
what what's the what's part of the
richness that's hard to simulate
uh i suppose the
complexity of the environment and your
position in that or the position of an
organism in that environment in the full
richness of that environment over its
entire life over multiple generations
with changes in gene
sequence over those generations so
slight changes in the makeup of those
individuals over generations but if you
take it back to the level of single
cells um which i do in in in the book
and and ask how do
how how does a single cell
in effect know it exists as an unit as
an entity i mean no in inverted commas
obviously it doesn't know
anything
but it acts as a unit and it acts with
astonishing
precision as a unit
and i had suggested that that's linked
to the electrical fields on on the
membranes themselves and that they give
some indication of how am i doing in
relation to my environment as a kind of
real-time feedback on the world
and
this is something physical
which can be
selected over generations that if you
are
if you get this wrong
um
it's linked with this set of
circumstances that i've just
as an individual
i have a moment of blind panic and run
um as a bacterium or something you have
a you know some electrical discharge
that says blind panic and it it runs
whatever it may be and you associate
over generations multiple generations
that this electrical phase that i'm in
now is associated with
a response like that and it's easy to
see how feelings come in through
through the back door almost with with
that that kind of
um
giving real-time feedback on your
position in the world in relation to how
how am i doing and then you you
complexify the system and yes i have no
problem with a with with phase
transition and i you know
can can all of this be done
um
purely by
the language by the the the issues with
how the system understands itself
maybe it can i honestly don't know
um but i i you know the philosophers for
a long time have talked about uh the
possibility that you can
have a zombie intelligence
uh and that there are no feelings there
but all everything else is the same um
is i mean i have to throw this back to
you really how do you deal with zombie
intelligence
so first of all i can see that from a
biologist's perspective
you think of all the complexities that
led up to the human being
the entirety of the history of four
billion years that in some deep sense
integrated the human being into this
environment and that
dance of the organism and the
environment
you could see how emotions arise from
that and their emotions are deeply
connected and creating a human
experience and from that you mix in
consciousness and
the fullness of it yeah uh but
from a perspective of an intelligent
organism that's already here
like a baby that learns
it doesn't need to learn how to
be a collection of cells or how to do
all the things he needs to do it's
the basic function of a baby as it
learns is to interact with its
environment to learn from its
environment to learn how to fit in to
this social society to like um and the
the basic uh
response of the baby is to cry a lot of
the time cry uh to uh well maybe
convince the humans to
to protect it
or to discipline it to teach it what if
i mean uh we've developed a bunch of
different tricks uh how to get our
parents or to take care of us to educate
us to teach us about the world also
we've constructed the world in such a
way that it's safe enough for us to
survive in and yet dangerous enough to
learn the valuable lessons like the
tables are still hard with corners so it
can still run into them it hurts like
how
so ai needs to solve that problem not
the problem of constructing this super
complex organism that leads up
uh
so you to run the whole
um
you know to make an apple pie to build
the whole universe you need to build the
whole universe i think the the zombie
question is uh
it's something
i would leave to the philosophers
because
uh and i will also leave to them the
definition of love and what is
what happens between two human beings
when there's a magic
that just grabs them
like uh nothing else matters in the
world and somehow you've been searching
for this feeling this moment this person
your whole life that feeling
um
the philosophers can have a lot of fun
with that one and also say that that's
just uh you could have a biological
explanation you can have all kinds of
it's all fake it's uh actually ein rand
will say it's all selfish there's a lot
of different interpretations i'll leave
it to the philosophers the point is the
feeling
surest health feels very real
and if my toaster
makes me feel
like it's the only toaster in the world
and when i leave
and i miss the toaster and when i come
back i'm excited to see the toaster and
my life is meaningful and joyful and the
friends i have around me
get it get a better version of me
because that toaster exists
that sure as hell feels i mean
is that psychologically different to
having a dog
no because i mean most people would
dispute whether we can say a dog i would
i would say dog is undoubtedly conscious
but
but but some people there's degrees of
consciousness and so on but people are
definitely much more uncomfortable
saying a toaster yeah conscious than a
dog
and
there's still a deep connection you
could say our relationship with the dog
has more to do with anthropomorphism
like we kind of project the human being
onto it maybe we can do the same damn
thing with a toaster yes but you can
look into the dog's eyes and you can see
that it's uh it's sad that it's it's
delighted to see you again i don't have
a dog by the way i don't know it's not
that i'm
incredibly good at using their eyes they
do just that
they are now i don't imagine that a dog
is remotely as close to being
intelligent as a as an ai
intelligence
but um
it's certainly capable of communicating
emotionally with us but here's what i
would venture to say we tend to think
because ad plays chess well yeah and is
able to fold proteins now well
that it's intelligent i would argue that
in order to communicate with humans in
order to have emotional intelligence it
actually requires another order of
magnitude of intelligence it's not easy
to be
flawed
solving a mathematical puzzle is not the
same as
the full complexity of human to human
interaction that's actually
we humans just
take for granted the things we're really
good at
non-stop people tell me how shitty
people are driving
no
humans are incredible at driving uh
bipedal walking walking object
manipulation we're incredible at this
and so people tend to
discount the things we all just take for
granted and one of those things that
they discount is our ability
the dance of conversation and
interaction with each other the the
ability to morph ideas together the
ability to get angry at each other
and then to miss each other like to
create attention that makes life fun and
difficult and challenging in a way
that's meaningful that is
a skill that's learned and ai would need
to solve that problem i mean in some
sense what you're saying is
a ai cannot become meaningfully
emotional let's say until it experiences
some kind of internal conflict that is
unable to reconcile these various
aspects of reality or its reality
with
with a decision to make
and then it feels sad necessarily
because
it doesn't know what to do
and i i certainly can't dispute that
that may very well be how it works i
think the only way to find out is to do
it and just build it yeah and leave it
to the philosophers if it actually feels
sad or not
the point is the robot will be sitting
there alone having an internal conflict
an existential crisis and that's
required for it to have a deep
meaningful connection with another human
being now does it actually feel that i
don't know but i'd like to throw
something else at you which which
troubles me uh on reading it um
uh noah harrari's book 21 lessons for
the 21st century and he's written about
this kind of thing on various occasions
and he sees biochemistry as an algorithm
and then ai will necessarily be able to
hack that algorithm and do it better
than humans so there will be a.i better
at writing music that we appreciate the
mozart ever called or writing better
than shakespeare ever did and so on
because
biochemistry is algorithmic and all you
need to do is figure out which bits of
the algorithm to play to make us feel
good or bad or appreciate things
and it's a as a biochemist i find that
argument
close to irrefutable and not very
enjoyable
i don't like the sound of it that's just
my reaction as a human being you might
like the sound of it because that says
that ai is is capable of the same kind
of
uh emotional feelings about the world as
as we are because the whole thing is an
algorithm and you can program an
algorithm
and and there you are
he then has a peculiar final chapter
where he talks about consciousness in
rather separate terms and he's talking
about meditating and so on and getting
in touch with his inner conscious i
don't meditate i don't know anything
about that
but he wrote in very different terms
about it
as if somehow it's a way out of the
algorithm
um now
it seems to me that consciousness in
that sense is capable of scuppering the
algorithm i think in terms of the
biochemical feedback loops and so on it
is undoubtedly algorithmic
but in terms of what we decide to do
it can be much more
um
based on an emotion we can just think i
don't care i can't resolve this complex
situation
i'm going to do that
and that can be based on in effect a
different currency which is the currency
of feelings and something where we don't
have very much personal control over and
then it comes back around to to to you
and what you what are you trying to get
at with ai do we need to have some
system which is capable of overriding
a rational decision which cannot be made
because there's too much conflicting
information
by
effectively an emotional judgmental
decision that just says do this and see
what happens yeah that's what
consciousness is really doing in my view
yeah and the question is whether it's a
different process or just a higher level
process
um i might you know
the idea that biochemistry is an
algorithm
is uh to me an over simplistic view
there's a lot of things that
the moment you say it
it's irrefutable but it simplifies
i'm sure it's an extreme and in the
process
loses something fundamental so for
example
calling a universe an information
processing system
sure yes
you could you could make that it's a
computer that's performing computations
but you're
missing
uh the
the process of
uh the entropy somehow leading to
pockets of complexity that creates these
beautiful artifacts that are incredibly
complex and they're like machines and
then those machines are through the
process of evolution are constructing
even further complexity
like
in calling universe information
processing machine
you're
you're missing those little local
pockets and how difficult it is to
create them so the question to me is if
biochemistry is an algorithm how
difficult is it to create in a software
system okay that runs the human body
which i think is incorrect i think we're
that is going to take so long
i can't i mean that's going to be
centuries from now to be able to
reconstruct a human now what i would
venture to say to get some of the magic
of a human being
with what we saying with the emotions
and the interactions and like like a dog
makes us smile and joyful and all those
kinds of things that will come much
sooner but that doesn't require us to
reverse engineer the algorithm of
biochemistry yes but
the toaster is making you happy yes
it's not about whether you make the
toast happy
um no it has to so
it has to be
it has to be the toaster has to be able
to leave me happy yeah because the
toaster is the ai in this case is a very
interesting the toaster has to be able
to be unhappy and leave me
that's essential
yeah that's essential for my being able
to miss the toaster if the toaster is
just my servant
that's not or a provider of like
services
like tells me the weather makes toast
that's not going to deep connection it
has to have internal conflict you write
about life and death it has to be able
to be conscious of its mortality
and the finiteness of its existence
and that life is for temporary and
therefore it needs to be more selective
what are those
hangs out moving moments in the movies
from when i was a boy was the the
unplugging of hal in 2001 where
that was the death of a sentient being
and
hal knew it
so i think we
we all kind of know
that
that a sufficiently
intelligent being is going to
have some form of consciousness but
whether
it would be back like biological
consciousness i just don't know and if
you're thinking about how do we bring
together i mean obviously we're going to
interact
um more closely with with ai
but
are we really
is is a is a dog really like a toaster
or is there really some kind of
difference there you were talking ab you
know biochemistry is algorithmic uh but
it's not single algorithm and it's very
complex of course it is so it may be
that there's there are again conflicts
in the circuits of biochemistry but i
have a feeling
that the level of complexity of
the total biochemical system at the
level of a single cell is less complex
than the the level of neural networking
in the human brain or in an ai
well i guess i assumed that we were
including the brain in the biochemistry
algorithm
because you have to
uh i would see that as a higher level of
organization of neural networks they're
all using the same biochemical wiring
within themselves
yeah but the human brain is not just
neurons
it's the immune system it's it's the
whole package
i mean to have a biochemical algorithm
that runs a
uh intelligent biological system you
have to include the whole damn thing and
it's pretty fascinating it comes from
like
from an embryo
like the whole i mean oh boy
i mean if you can um
what is a human being
because it's but if you look just some
code and then you build and then that so
it's dna doesn't just tell you what to
build but how to build it
is it
i mean the thing is impressive and the
question is how
uh
difficult is it to reverse engineer the
whole shebang
very difficult i i would say it's
don't want to say impossible but
it is
like it's much easier to build a human
than to reverse engineer
uh
to build like a fake human
human-like thing
than to reverse engineer the entirety of
the process the evolution of
her i'm not sure if we are capable of
reverse engineering the whole thing yeah
if our if the human mind is capable of
doing that i mean
i wouldn't be a biologist if i wasn't
trying yeah um but
i know i can't understand the whole
problem i'm just trying to understand
the rudimentary outlines of the problem
there's another aspect though you're
talking about developing from a single
cell to a to a to the human mind and all
the
part system subsystems that are part of
in the immune system and so on
um
this is something
that you'll talk about i imagine um with
uh with michael levin
but
the
so little is known
about you talk about reverse engineers
so little is known about the
developmental pathways that go from a
genome to going to a fully wired
organism
um and a lot of it seems to depend on
the same intellect
electrical interactions that i was
talking about happening at the level of
single cells and its interaction with
the environment there's there's a whole
electrical field side to biology
that is not yet written into any of the
textbooks
which is about how does an embryo
develop into our single cell develop
into into these complex systems what
defines the head what defines the immune
system what defines the brain and so on
that really is written in a language
that we're only just beginning to
understand and frankly biologists most
biologists are still very reluctant to
even
get themselves tangled up in questions
like electrical fields influencing
development it seems like mumbo jumbo to
a lot of biologists and it should not be
because this is the 21st century biology
this is where it's going uh but we're
not going to reverse engineer a human
being or the mind or any of these
subsystems until we understand how this
developmental process well how
electricity in biology really works and
and if it is
linked with
feelings of with consciousness and so on
that's the stamin in the meantime we
have to try but but i think that's where
the answer lies
so you think uh it's possible that the
key to things like consciousness
are some of the more
tricky aspects of cognition might lie in
that early development
the interaction of electricity and
biology
electrical fields
but we already know the eeg and so on is
telling us a lot about brain function
but we don't know which cells which
parts of a neural network is giving rise
to the eeg we don't know the basics the
assumption is
i mean we know it's neural networks we
know it's multiple cells hundreds or
thousands of cells involved in it and we
assume that it's to do with
depolarization
during action potentials and so on
but the mitochondria which are in there
have much more membranes than the plasma
membrane of the neuron and there's a
much greater membrane potential and it's
formed in
parallel very often parallel christie
which are capable of of um reinforcing a
field and generating fields over longer
distances
um
and nobody knows if that plays a role in
consciousness or not there's reasons to
argue that it could but frankly we we
simply do not know
and it's not taken into consideration
you look at the the structure of the
mitochondrial membranes
in the brains of you know simple things
like drosophila uh the fruit fly and
they have amazing structures you can see
lots of little rectangular things all
lined up uh
in in in in amazing patterns what are
they doing why are they like that we
haven't the first clue
what do you think about
organoids and brain organoids and like
so in a lab trying to uh study the
development of these
in the
uh in the petri dish
development of organs
do you think that's promising do you
have to look at whole systems i've never
done anything like that i don't know
much about it the people who i've talked
to who do work on it say amazing things
can happen and that you know a bit of a
brain grown in a in a dish is capable of
experiencing some kind of feelings or
even memories of its former brain
again i i have a feeling that until we
understand how to control the electrical
fields that that control development
we're not going to understand how to
turn an organoid into a real functional
system
but how do to get that understanding
it's so
it's so incredibly difficult i mean you
would have to
i mean one promising direction i'd love
to get your opinion on this um i don't
know if you're familiar with the work of
deep mind and alpha fold with protein
folding and so on do you think it's
possible
that that will give us some
breakthroughs in biology trying to
basically simulate
and model the behavior of
trivial biological systems
as they become complex biological
systems
i'm sure it will
the interesting thing to me about
protein folding
is that
for a long time my understanding is not
what i work on so i may have got this
wrong but my understanding is that you
you take the sequence the sequence of a
protein
and you try to fold it um in and there
are multiple ways in which you can fold
and to come up with the correct
conformation is not a very easy thing
because you're doing it from first
principles from a string of letters
which specify the string of amino acids
but what actually happens
is when a protein is coming out of a
ribosome
it's coming out of a charged tunnel and
it's in a very specific environment
which is going to force this to go there
now and then this one to go there and
this one to come like and so you're
forcing a specific conformational set of
changes onto it as it comes out of the
ribosome so by the time it's fully
emerged it's already got its shape and
that shape depended on
on on on the immediate environment that
it was emerging into one letter as one
one one amino acid at a time
and i don't think that the field
was looking at it that way
and this is if if that's correct then
that's very characteristic of science
which is to say it asks very often the
wrong question and then does really
amazingly sophisticated analyses on
something having never thought to
actually think well what is biology
doing in biology is giving you a charged
electrical environment that forces you
to be this way now did
deep mind
come up through patterns with some
answer that was like that i've got
absolutely no idea it bought to be
possible to deduce that
from the shapes of proteins it would
require much greater
much greater
skill than the human mind has
but the human mind is capable of saying
well hang on let's look at this exit
tunnel and try and work out what shape
is this protein going to take well they
can figure that out that's really
interesting about the exit tunnel but
like sometimes we get lucky and
our like just second science
the simplified view or the static view
uh will actually solve the problem for
us so in this case it's very possible
that the sequence of letters has a
unique mapping to our structure without
considering how
it unraveled so without considering the
tunnel and so and that seems to be the
case
in this situation with the the cool
thing about proteins all the different
shapes that can possibly take it
actually seems to take
very specific unique shapes given the
sequence that's forced on you by an exit
tunnel so the problem is actually much
simpler than you thought and then
there's a whole army of
of uh proteins that
uh which change the conformational state
uh chaperone proteins and they're only
used when
when there's some presumably issue with
how it came out of the exit tunnel and
you want to do it differently to that so
very often the chaperone proteins will
go there and will influence the way in
which it falls
so
there's two ways of doing it either you
can you can look at the structures and
the sequences of all the proteins and
you can apply an immense mind to it and
figure out what the patterns are and
figure out what or you can look at the
actual situation where it is and say
well hang on it was actually quite
simple it's got a charged environment
and of course it's forced to come out
this way and then the question would be
well do different ribosomes have
different charged environments what
happens if a chaparral you know you're
asking a different set of questions to
come to the same answer in a way which
is telling you
a much simpler story and explains why it
is rather than saying it could be
this is one in a in a billion different
possible conformational states that this
protein could have you're saying well it
has this one because that was
the only one it could take given its
setting
well yeah i mean there's currently
humans are very good at that kind of
first principles thinking oh yeah
stepping back but i think ai is really
good at you know collect a huge amount
of data
and a huge amount of data of observation
of planets and figure out that earth is
not at the center of the universe that
there's actually a sun we're
orbiting the sun but then you can as a
human being ask well how did how do
solar systems come to be how do it
what are the different forces that are
required to make this kind of pattern
emerge and then you start to invent
things like gravity what i mean
obviously
i mixed up the ordering of of uh gravity
wasn't considered as a thing that
connects planets but
um
we are able to think about those big
picture things as human beings
ai is just very good to infer
simple models from a huge amount of
um
data
and the question is with biology you
know we kind of go back and forth how we
solve biology listen protein folding was
thought to be impossible to solve and
there's a lot of brilliant phd students
that worked one protein at a time trying
to figure out the structure and the fact
that i was able to do that
oh i'm not i'm not
knocking it at all but uh but but i
think that people have been asking the
wrong question but then
as the people start to ask better
and bigger questions
the ai kind of enters the chat and says
i'll help you out with that
can i give you another example of my own
work
um
the the risk of getting a disease as we
get older
um
there are genetic aspects to it you know
if you spend your whole life
overeating and smoking and whatever
that's a whole separate question
but there's a genetic side to the risk
and and we know a few genes that
increase your risk of certain things and
for for probably 20 years now people
have been doing what's called g wasps
which is um genome-wide association
studies so you you've effectively
scanned the entire genome for any
single nucleotide polymorphisms which is
say a single letter change in one place
that has a higher association of being
linked with a particular disease or not
and you can come up with thousands of
these things across the genome
and
if you add them all up
and try and say well so do they add up
to uh to explain the the known genetic
risk of this disease and the known
genetic risk often comes from twin
studies and you can say that you know
that if if this twin gets
epilepsy there's a 40 or 50 risk that
the other twin identical twin will also
get epilepsy therefore the genetic
factor is about 50 percent uh and so the
the gene
similarities that you see should account
for 50
of that known risk
very often it accounts for less than a
tenth of the known risk
and there's two possible explanations
and there's one which people tend to do
which is to say ah well we don't have
enough statistical power if we maybe
there's maybe there's a million we've
only found a thousand of them but if we
found the other million they're weakly
related but there's a huge number of
them and so we'll account for that whole
risk maybe there's i mean you know maybe
there's a billion of them for instance
so so that's one way the other way is to
say
well hang on a minute you're missing a
system here that system is the
mitochondrial dna which people tend to
dismiss because it's small and it's not
uh it doesn't change very much
but a few
single letter changes in that
mitochondrial dna it it controls some
really basic processes it controls
not only all the energy that we need to
live and to move around and do
everything we do but also biosynthesis
to make the new building blocks to you
know
to to to make new cells and cancer cells
very often kind of take over the
mitochondria and rewire them so that
instead of using them for making energy
they're effectively using them as
precursors for the building blocks for
biosynthesis you need to make new amino
acids new nucleotides for dna you want
to make new lipids to make your
membranes and so on so they kind of
rewire metabolism now the problem is
that we've got all these interactions
between mitochondrial dna and the genes
in the nucleus
that are overlooked completely because
people throw away literally throw away
the mitochondrial genes and we can see
in in fruit flies that they interact and
produce
big differences in risk
so you can set
uh you can set ai onto this question of
exactly what
uh you know how many of these base
changes there are and this is one
possible solution that maybe
there are a million of them and it does
account for the great part of the risk
well the other one is they aren't it's
just not there that actually the risk
lies in something you weren't even
looking at and this is where human
intuition
is very important and just this feeling
that well i'm working on this and i
think it's important and i'm bloody
minded about it and in the end some
people are right it turns out that it
was important
can you get ai to do that to be
bloody-minded
and uh that that that hang on a minute
you might be missing a whole other
system here that's much bigger
that's that's huma that's
that's the moment of discovery of
scientific revolution
i'm
giving up on saying hey i can't do
something
i've said it enough times about enough
things i think there's been a lot of
progress
and uh instead i'm excited by the
possibility of ai helping humans but at
the same time just like i said we seem
to dismiss the power of humans yes yes
like we're so limited
in so many ways
uh
that kind of
in in what we feel like dumb ways like
we're not strong
we're uh we're kind of
um
our attention our memory is limited our
ability to focus on things is limited
in our own perception of what limited is
but that actually there's an incredible
computer behind the whole thing that
makes this whole system work our ability
to
interact with the environment to reason
about the environment there's magic
there and i i'm hopeful that ai can
capture some of that same magic but that
magic is not going to look like uh deep
blue playing chess no it's going to be
more interesting but i don't think it's
going to look like a pattern finding
either i mean that's essentially what
you're telling me it does very well at
the moment and my point is
it works very well where you're looking
for the right pattern but we are
storytelling animals and the hypothesis
is a story
it's a testable story but but you know a
new hypothesis is a leap into the
unknown and it's a new story basically
and it says uh this leads to this leads
to that it's a causal set of of of
storytelling
it's also possible that the leap into
the unknown has a pattern of its own yes
it is
possible let's learn learnable
i'm sure it is there's a nice uh book by
arthur cursler on um
on on the nature of creativity and and
he likens it to a joke where the
punchline goes off in a completely
unexpected direction and says that this
is the basis of
human creativity that you know some
creative switch of direction to an
unexpected place is similar to to a
i'm not saying that's how it works but
it's a nice idea and there's must be
some truth in it
um
and it's one of these
most of the stories we tell are probably
the wrong story and probably going
nowhere and probably not helpful and we
definitely don't do as well at seeing
patterns in things but some of the most
enjoyable human aspects is is finding a
new story that goes to an unexpected
place and these are all aspects of what
being human means to me
um and maybe these are all things that
that ai figures out for itself or maybe
they're just aspects
but i i just have the feeling sometimes
that the people who
are trying to
understand what to
what we are like what weird what we if
we wish to craft an ai system which is
somehow human-like
that we don't have a firm enough
grasp of
what humans really are like in terms of
how we are built
but we uh get a better better
understanding of that i agree with you
completely we try to build the thing and
then we'll go
hang on in a minute yeah
there's another system here and that's
actually the attempt to build ai
that's human-like is getting us to a
deeper understanding of human beings
the funny thing i recently talked to
magnus carlson the widely considered to
be the greatest chess player of all time
and he talked about alpha zero which is
a system from deepmind that plays chess
and he had a funny comment
um he has a kind of dry sense of humor
but he was extremely impressed when he
first saw alpha zero play
and he said that it did a lot of things
that could easily be mistaken for
creativity
[Laughter]
uh so he like refute as a typical human
refused to give the system
sort of it's due because he came up with
a lot of things that a lot of people
are extremely impressed by not just the
sheer calculation but
the the brilliance of play so one of the
things that um
it does
in really interesting ways is it
sacrifices pieces
so in chess that means you you you
basically take a few steps back in order
to take a step forward you give away
pieces for some future reward
and that
for us humans is where art is in chess
you take big risks
that
uh for us humans
those risks are especially painful
because
you have a fog of uncertainty before you
so to take a risk now based on the
intuition of i think this is the right
risk to take but there's so many
possibilities that that's where it takes
guts that's where art is that's that
danger and then
the
alpha
alpha zero takes those same kind of
risks and does them even greater degree
but of course
it does it from a
well you could easily
uh reduce down to a
cold
calculation over patterns but
boy when you see the final result it
sure looks like the same kind of magic
that we see in creativity
uh when we see creative play on the
chessboard but the chessboard is very
limited and the question is as we get
better and better can we
do that same kind of creativity
in mathematics
in programming
and then adventuring biology psychology
and expand into more and more complex
systems
i was um
used to go running when i was a boy and
fell running which is say running up and
down mountains and i was never
particularly great at it but
there were some people who were
amazingly fast especially at running
down
uh and i i realized in trying to do this
that um there's
there's only really two two way there's
three possible ways of doing it and
there's only two that work either you go
extremely slowly and carefully and you
figure out okay there's a stone i'll put
my foot on this stone and then there's
another there's a muddy puddle i'm going
to avoid and you know it's slow it's
laborious you figure it out step by step
or you can just go incredibly fast and
you don't think about it at all the
entire conscious mind is shut out of it
and it's probably the same playing table
tennis or something there's something in
the mind which is doing a whole lot of
subconscious calculations about exactly
and it's amazing you can run at
astonishing speed down a hillside with
no idea how you did it at all
and then you panic and you think i'm
going to break my leg if i keep doing
this i've got to think about where i'm
going to put my foot so you slow down a
bit and try to bring those conscious
mind in and then you you do you crash
you can't you can you cannot think
consciously while running downhill
and so it's amazing
it's amazing how many calculations the
mind is able to make
and now the problem with playing chess
or something if you were able to make
all of those subconscious kind of
forward calculations about
what what is the likely outcome of this
move now
uh in the way that we can by running
down a hillside or something is it you
know it's partly about what we have
adapted to do it's partly about the
reality of the world that we're in
running fast downhill is something that
we better be bloody good at otherwise
we're going to be eaten um
whereas whereas
trying to calculate
multiple multiple moves into the future
is not something we've ever been called
on to do two or three four moves into
the future is quite enough for most of
us most of the time
yeah
yeah so the yeah just solving chess may
not um
we may not be as far towards solving the
problem of uh downhill running
as we might think just because we solved
chess
still it's beautiful to see
creativity humans create machines
they're able to create art
and art on the chessboard and art
otherwise
who knows how far that takes us
so i mentioned andre carpathi earlier
him and i are big fans of yours if
you're taking votes his suggestion was
you should write your next book on the
fermi paradox
so let me ask you on the topic of uh
alien life
since we've been talking about life and
we're a kind of aliens
how many alien civilizations are out
there do you think
well the universe is very big
so some
but not as many as most people would
like to think is my view because the
idea that
that there is a trajectory going from
simple simple cellular life like
bacteria all the way through to humans
it seems to me there's some big gaps
along that way the the eukaryotic cell
the the complex cell that we have is is
the biggest of them but also
photosynthesis is another the other
another interesting gap is a long gap
from from the origin of the eukaryotic
cell to the first animals that was about
a billion years
uh maybe more than that
um a long delay in when oxygen began to
accumulate in the atmosphere so from the
first appearance of oxygen in the great
oxidation event who were enough for
animals to respire
it was close to two billion years
um
why so long it seems to be planetary
factors it seems to be geology as much
as in anything else and we don't really
know
what was going on
so the idea that there's a kind of an
inevitable
march towards uh
complexity and and um
sentient life i don't think he's right
doesn't not to say it's not going to
happen
but i think it's not going to happen
often
so if you think of earth given the
geological constraints and all that kind
of stuff
do you have a sense that life complex
life intelligent life happen really
quickly on earth over the long
so
just just to get a sense of
are you more sort of saying that it's
very unlikely to get the kind of
conditions required to create humans or
is it even if you have the condition
it's just statistically difficult i
think the i mean the problem the single
great problem at the center of all of
that to my mind is the origin of the
eukaryotic cell which happened once and
without eukaryotes nothing else would
have happened
and and that is something that
that's because you're saying it's super
important the eukaryotes but i'm saying
tantamount to saying that it is
impossible to build something as complex
as a human being from bacterial cells i
totally agree in some deep fundamental
way but it's just like a one cell going
inside another
it's not so difficult to get to work
right like
well again it happened once
um and
if you think about if you if you think
i mean i'm in a minority view in this
position most biologists probably
wouldn't agree with me anyway but if you
think about the the starting point we've
we've got a simple cell it's an archaeal
cell we can be fairly sure about that so
it looks a lot like a bacterium
but is in fact from this other other
domain of life so it looks a lot like a
bacterial cell that means it doesn't
have anything it doesn't have a nucleus
it doesn't really have
complex endo membrane it has it has a
little bit of stuff but not not that
much
and it takes up an endless inbound
so what happens
next
and the answer is basically everything
to do with complexity
to me there's a beautiful paradox here
plants and animals and fungi
all have exactly the same type of cell
but they all have really different ways
of living so a plant cell
it's photosynthetic
they started out as algae in the oceans
and so on so think of algal blooms
single cell things you know the the
basic
uh
the basic cell structure that it's built
from is exactly the same with a couple
of small differences it's got
chloroplasts as well it's got a vacuole
it's got a cell wall but that's about it
pretty much everything else is exactly
the same in a plant cell and an animal
cell
and yet the ways of life are completely
different so this these this cell
structure did not evolve in response to
different ways of life different
environments i'm in the ocean doing
photosynthesis i'm on land running
around as part of an animal uh i'm a
fungus in a soil
spending out long kind of shoots into
whatever it may be
mycelium so
they all have the same underlying cell
structure why
almost certainly it was driven by
adaptation to the internal environment
to having these pesky endosymbionts
forced all kinds of change on on the
host cell now in one way you could see
that as a really good thing because it
may be that there's some inevitability
to this process as soon as you've got
endless imbalance you're more or less
bound to go in that direction or it
could be that there's a huge fluke about
it and it's almost certain to go wrong
in just about every case possible that
the conflict will lead to effectively
war leading to death and extinction uh
and it simply doesn't work out so maybe
it happened millions of times and it
went wrong every time or maybe it only
happened once
and it worked out because it was
inevitable and actually we simply do not
know enough now to say which of those
two possibilities is true but both of
them are a bit grim but you're
you're leaning towards
we just got really lucky in that one
leap
like we got so do you have a sense that
our galaxy for example has just
maybe millions of planets with bacteria
living on it i would expect billions
tens of billions of planets with
bacteria living on it practically i
would i would i mean there's probably
what five to ten planets per star
of which i would hope that at least one
would have bacteria on
so i expect bacteria to be very common
i i simply can't put a number otherwise
i mean i expect it will happen elsewhere
it's not that i think we're living in a
completely empty universe that's so fast
but i think that it's not going to
happen inevitably and there's something
you know it wasn't that's not the only
problem with uh with with
complex life on earth i mentioned oxygen
animals and so on as well and even
humans we came along very late you go
back five million years and you know
would we be that impressed if we came
across a planet full of giraffes
i mean you'd think hey there's life here
and there's a nice planet to colonize or
something we wouldn't think oh let's try
and have a conversation with this
giraffe
yeah i'm not sure what exactly we would
think
i'm not exactly sure what makes humans
so interesting from an alien perspective
or how they would notice i'll talk to
you about cities too because that's an
interesting perspective of uh how to
look at human civilization
but your sense i mean of course you
don't know but it's an interesting
world it's an interesting galaxy it's an
interesting universe to live in that's
just like
every sun
like 90 percent
of uh
solar systems
have bacteria in it
like imagine that world
and
the galaxy maybe has
just a handful if not one
intelligent civilization
that's a wild world and so wow i didn't
even even think about that world there's
a kind of
thought that
like one of the reasons it would be so
exciting to find life on mars or titan
or whatever it's like if it's life is
elsewhere then surely
statistically
that life no matter how unlikely your
query has multi-cell organisms
sex
violence
what what else is extremely difficult i
mean uh photosynthesis
is figuring out some machinery that
involves the chemistry and the
environment to allow the building up of
complex organisms surely that would
arise
but man i don't know how i would feel
about just bacteria everywhere well it
would be depressing if it was true
i suppose
i don't think natural i don't know
what's more depressing bacteria
everywhere nothing everywhere
yes either of them are chilling yeah but
whether it's chilling or not i don't
think should
force us to change our view about
whether it's real or not
and what i'm saying may or may not be
true so how would you feel if we
discovered life on mars
absolutely it sounds like you would be
less excited than some others
because you're like well what i would be
most interested in is how similar to
life on earth it would be it would
actually turn into quite a subtle
problem because
the
the likelihood of life having gone to
and fro between between mars and the
earth is
is quite i wouldn't say high but it's
not low it's quite feasible
and so if we found life on mars and it
had
very similar genetic code but it was
slightly different
most people would interpret that
immediately as evidence that they've
been transit one way or the other and
that it was a it was a common origin of
life on mars or on the earth and he went
one way the other way the other way to
see that question though would be to say
well actually though the beginnings of
life lie in deterministic chemistry and
thermodynamics starting with the most
likely abundant materials co2 and water
and a wet rocky planet and mars was wet
and rocky at the beginning uh and will i
won't say inevitably but potentially
almost inevitably come up with a genetic
code which is not very far away from the
genetic code that we already have
so we see subtle differences in the
genetic code what does it mean it could
be very difficult to interpret is it
possible you think to tell the
difference
or something that truly originated
i think if the stereochemistry was
different
we have sugars for example that are the
l form or the d form and and
we have
uh d sugars and l amino acids right
across all of life but lipids
uh we have the bacteria have one one
stereoisomer and the bacteria have the
other the opposite stereoisomer
so it's perfectly possible to use one or
the other one
uh and the same would almost certainly
go for i think george church
has been trying to make life based on
the opposite stereoisomer
so it's perfectly possible to do and it
will work um
and if we were to find life on mars that
was using the opposite stereoisomer that
would be unequivocal evidence that life
had started independently there so
hopefully
the life we find will be on titan and
europa or something like that where it's
less likely that we shared and it's
harsher conditions so there's going to
be weirder kind of life
i wouldn't count on that because
life started in deep sea hydrothermal
vents it's harsh that's pretty harsh
yeah so titan is different europa is
probably quite similar to earth in the
sense that we're dealing with an ocean
it's an acidic ocean there
um as the early earth would have been
and it almost only has hydrothermal
systems same with enceladus we can tell
that from these plumes coming from the
surface through the ice we know there's
a liquid ocean and we we can tell
roughly what the chemistry is
for titan we're dealing with liquid
methane and things like that so that
would really if there really is life
there it would really have to be very
very different to anything
uh that we know on earth
so the hard leap the hardest sleep the
most important leap is from
precarious to to eukaryotes eukaryotic
what's the second
if we're ranking what's what's the
what's uh you gave a lot of emphasis on
photosynthesis yeah and that would be my
second one i think but it's it's not so
much i mean photosynthesis is part of
the problem
it's a difficult thing to do
again
we know it happened once we don't know
why it happened once
um
but
the fact that
it
was kind of taken on board completely by
plants and algae and so on as
chloroplasts
and
did very well in completely different
environments and then on land and
whatever else seems to suggest that
there's no
there's no problem with exploring
whether you know you could have a
separate origin that explored this whole
domain over there that the bacteria had
never gone into
um
so that kind of says that the reason
that it only happened once is probably
because it's difficult because the
wiring is difficult
yeah um but then it it happened at least
2.2 billion years ago right before the
goe maybe as long as three billion years
ago when there are some people say there
are whiffs of oxygen there's just kind
of traces in the fossil in the in the
geochemical record that say maybe
there's a bit of oxygen then that's
really disputed some people say he goes
all the way back four billion years ago
and and um it was the common ancestor of
life on earth was photosynthetic so
immediately you've got you know groups
of people who disagree over a two
billion year period of time about when
it started
um but well
let's take the latest date when it's
unequivocal that's 2.2 billion years ago
through to around about the time of the
cambrian explosion when oxygen levels
definitely got close to modern levels uh
which was around about 550 million years
ago so we've gone more than one and a
half billion years
where the earth was in stasis
um nothing much changed it's known as
the boring billion in fact
um uh probably stuff was that was when
you carries arose somewhere in there but
it's uh
so this idea that the world is
constantly changing that we're
constantly evolving that we're moving up
some ramp it's a very human idea but in
reality
though
there are
um
there there are kind of
tipping points to a new stable
equilibrium where the
cells that are producing oxygen are
precisely counterbalanced by the cells
that are consuming that oxygen which is
why it's 21
now and has been that way for hundreds
of millions of years we have a very
precise balance you go through a tipping
point and you don't know where the next
stable state is going to be but it can
be a long way from here
and so if we change the world with
global warming there will be a tipping
point question is where and when and
what's the next stable state it may be
uninhabitable to us it'll be habitable
to life
for sure
but there may be something like the
permian extinction where 95 of species
go extinct and there's a five to ten
million year gap and then life recovers
but
without humans and the question
statistically well without humans but
statistically does that ultimately lead
to greater complexity more interesting
life
more intense well after the first
appearance of oxygen
with the goe there was a tipping point
which led to a long-term stable state
that was equivalent to the black sea
today which is to say oxygenated at the
very surface and stagnant sterile not
sterile but um but sulfurous lower down
um
and
and that was stable certainly around the
continental margins for more than a
billion years uh it was not a state that
led to progression in an obvious way
um
yeah i mean it's interesting to think
about evolution like what leads to
stable states
and uh
how often are
evolutionary pressures
emerging from the environment
so
maybe other planets are able to create
evolutionary pressures chemical
pressures whatever some kind of pressure
that say you're screwed unless you get
your [ __ ] together in the next
like
10 000 years like a lot of pressure
uh it seems like earth like the boring
building might be explained
in two ways one it's super difficult to
take any kind of next step
and uh the second way could be explained
is there's no reason to take the next
step no i think there is no reason but
at the end of it there was a there was a
snowball earth
um so there was a planetary catastrophe
on a huge scale where the the the
ice was the the sea was frozen at the
equator
um
and that forced change
in one way or another it's not long
after that 100 million years perhaps
after that so not short time but this is
when we begin to see animals there was a
shift again another tipping point that
led to catastrophic change that led to a
takeoff then
we don't really know why but one of the
reasons why that i discuss in the book
um
is about
sulfate being washed into the oceans
which sounds incredibly parochial
but
the
the issue is i mean that what the data
is showing we can we can track roughly
how oxygen was going into the atmosphere
from
um
from carbon isotopes so there's two
there's two main isotopes of carbon that
we need to think about here one is
carbon-12 99 of carbon is carbon-12 and
then one percent of carbon is carbon-13
which is a stable isotope and then
there's carbon-14 which is a trivial
radioactive estrogen amount
so 13 is one percent
and
life and enzymes generally
you can think of carbon atoms as
little balls bouncing around bing bong
balls bouncing around carbon 12 moves a
little bit faster than carbon 13 because
it's lighter
and it's more likely to encounter an
enzyme
and so it's more likely to be fixed into
organic matter
and so organic matter is enriched and
this is just an observation it's
enriched in carbon 12 by a few percent
compared to carbon 13 relative to what
you would expect if it was just equal
and
if you then bury organic matter
as coal or
oil or whatever it may be
then it's no longer oxidized so some
oxygen remains left over in in the
atmosphere and that's how oxygen
accumulates in the atmosphere and you
can work out historically how much
oxygen there must have been in the
atmosphere by how much
carbon was being buried and you think
well how can we possibly know how much
carbon was being buried and the answer
is well if you're burying carbon 12
what you're leaving behind is more
carbon 13 in the oceans and that
precipitates out in limestone so you can
look at limestones over these ages and
work out what's the carbon 13 signal
and that gives you a kind of a feedback
on what they want the oxygen content
right before the cambrian explosion
there was what's called a negative
isotope anomaly excursion which is
basically the carbon 13 goes down by a
massive amount and then back up again 10
million years later
and what that seems to be saying is the
amount of carbon 12 in the oceans
um
was was disappearing
which is to say it was being oxidized
um and if it's being oxidized it's
consuming oxygen and that should so a
big carbon 13 signal says that the ratio
of carbon 12 to carbon 13 is is really
going down which means there's
there's much more carbon 12 being taken
out and being oxidized sorry this is
getting too complex but well it's a good
it's a good way to estimate the amount
of oxygen if you calculate the amount of
oxygen based on the assumption that all
this carbon 12 that's being taken out is
being oxidized by oxygen the answer is
all the oxygen in the atmosphere gets
stripped out there is none left yeah um
and yet the rest of the geological
indicators say no there's oxygen in the
atmosphere
so it's a kind of a paradox and and the
only way to explain this paradox just on
mass balance of how much stuff is in the
air how much stuff is in the oceans and
so on um is to assume that it what
oxygen was not the oxygen it was sulfate
sulfate was being washed into the oceans
it's used as an electron acceptor by
sulfate reducing bacteria just as we use
oxygen as an electron acceptor so they
pass their electrons to sulfate instead
of oxygen
anterior did yeah yeah so these are
these are these are bacteria so they're
oxidizing carbon organic carbon
with sulfate passing the electrons onto
sulfate that
reacts with iron to form iron pyrites or
fool's gold sinks down to the bottom
gets buried out of the system
and this can account for the mass
balance so why does it matter
it matters because
what it says is there was a chance event
tectonically there was a lot of sulfate
sitting on land as a some kind of
mineral
so calcium sulfate minerals for example
are evaporitic
um and and um because there happened to
be some continents some continental
collisions mountain building this
sulfate was pushed up the side of a
mountain and happened to get washed into
the ocean
yeah so
many happy accidents like that are
possible statistically it's really hard
you know maybe you can roll that in
statistically or but this is the course
of life on earth without all that
sulfate being raised up this cambrian
explosion almost certainly would not
have happened
and then we wouldn't have had animals
and and so on and so on so it's you know
it's
this kind of explanation of the cambrian
explosion
so
uh let me actually say in several ways
so
you know folks who challenge the
validity of the uh
theory of evolution
will give us an example now i'm not well
studied in this but we'll give us an
example the camera and explosion is like
this thing is weird
oh i just wait
so
by
the question i would have
is what's the biggest mystery
or gap in understanding about evolution
is it the cambrian explosion and if so
how do we what's our best understanding
of how to explain
uh first of all what is it
in my understanding in the short amount
of time maybe 10 million years 100
million years something like that a huge
number of animals a variety diversity of
animals were created
um
anyway there's like five questions in
there yeah is that the biggest mystery
no i don't think that's a particularly
big mystery really anymore i mean it's
there are still mysteries about why then
and i've just said sulfate being washed
into the oceans is one it needs oxygen
and oxygen levels rose around that time
um so probably before that they weren't
high enough for animals what we're
seeing with the cambrian explosion is
the beginning of
predators and prey relationships we're
seeing we're seeing uh modern ecosystems
and we're seeing arms races and we're
seeing um
we're seeing the full creativity of
evolution unleashed
and the
so i talked about the boring billion
nothing happens for for you know one and
a half one billion years one and a half
billion years um
the assumption and this is completely
wrong this assumption is is that then
that you know evolution works really
slowly and that you need billions of
years to
affect some small change and then
another billion years to do something
else it's completely wrong
evolution gets stuck in a stasis and it
stays that way for tens of millions
hundreds of millions of years
uh and stephen j gould used to argue
this he called it punctuated equilibrium
but he was doing it to do with animals
and to do with the the last 500 million
years or so where it's much less obvious
than if you think about the entire
planetary history
and then you realize that the first two
billion years was bacteria only you have
the origin of life two billion years of
just bacteria oxygenic photosynthesis
arising here then you have a
global catastrophe snowball earths and
great oxidation events and then another
billion years of nothing happening and
then some some period of upheavals and
then another snowball earth and then
suddenly you see the cambrian explosion
this is long periods of stasis
where the world is in a stable state and
it's not lean is not geared towards
increasing complexity it's just
everything is in balance
and only when you have a catastrophic
level of global level problem like a
snowball earth it forces everything out
of balance and there's a tipping point
and you end up somewhere else now the
idea that that
evolution is slow
is wrong it can be incredibly fast
and i mentioned earlier on you can you
know in theory it would take half a
million years to invent an eye for
example from a light sensitive spot it
doesn't take long
to convert
uh you know
one one one kind of tube into a tube
with knobbles on it into a tube with
with with arms on it and then multiple
arms and and then at one end is the head
where that starts out as a swelling is
you know it's not
difficult consider intellectually to
understand how these things can happen
um
it boggles the mind that it can happen
so quickly but we're used to
human time scales and what we need to
talk about is generations of things that
live for a year in the ocean
um and and then a million years is a
million generations and the amount of
change that you can do it can affect in
in that period of time is enormous and
we're dealing with large populations of
things where selection is sensitive to
pretty small changes and can
uh so again what as soon as you throw in
the competition of predators and prey
and you're ramping up the the scale of
evolution it's not very surprising that
it happens very quickly when the
environment allows it to happen so i
don't think there's a big mystery
there's lots of details that need to be
filled in
i mean the big mystery in in biology is
consciousness
the big mystery in biology is conscious
well intelligence is kind of a mystery
too
i mean you said biology not
psychology
because
from a biology perspective it seems like
intelligence and consciousness all are
the same like weird
like
all the brain stuff i don't see this
intelligence is necessarily that
difficult i suppose i mean i see it as a
form of computing and i don't know much
about computing so i
you don't know much about consciousness
either so i i mean i suppose
oh i see
i see i see acid
that consciousness you do know a lot
about as a human being no no i mean i i
think i i can understand the wiring of a
brain
as a series of in pretty much the same
way as a computer in in theory
um
in terms of um the circuitry of it
the mystery
to me is
how this system gives rise to feelings
as we were talking about earlier on yeah
i just i think
i think we oversimplify
intelligence i think the dance the magic
of reasoning
is as interesting as the magic of
feeling
we we tend to
think of reasoning as like
very uh
running a very simplistic algorithm
i think reasoning is re the interplay
between memory whatever the hell is
going on the unconscious mind
all of that
um
i'm not trying to
diminish it in any way at all obviously
it's extraordinarily exquisitely complex
and
but but i don't see a logical difficulty
with how it works
yeah no i i mean i agree with you but
sometimes
um yeah there's a big cloak of mystery
around consciousness
i mean let me compare it with with
classical versus quantum physics the
classical physics
is logical and you can understand
the the kind of language we're dealing
with it's almost at the human level
we're dealing with stars and things that
we can see and when you get to quantum
mechanics and things
it's practically impossible for the
human mind to compute what is what just
happened there yeah um i mean that that
is the same it's like
you understand mathematically the the
notes of a musical composition that's
intelligence yes but why makes you feel
a certain way
that is much harder to understand
yeah that's that's really um
but
it was it was interesting framing that
that's a mystery at this at the core of
biology i wonder
who solves consciousness
i tend to think consciousness will be
solved by the engineer
meaning anything the person builds it
who tries keeps trying to build the
thing
uh versus biology is such a complicated
system
i feel like it's
um i feel like the building blocks of
consciousness from a biological
perspective
are like
that's like the final creation of a
human being so you have to understand
the whole damn thing
you said electrical fields but like
electrical fields plus plus everything
whole shebang
i'm inclined to agree i mean my feeling
is from my meager knowledge of the
history of science is that the biggest
breakthroughs usually come through from
a field that was not related to so so if
anyone you know is not going to be a
biologist who solves consciousness uh
just because biologists are too embedded
in in in the nature of of the problem
and then nobody's going to believe you
when you've done it because nobody's
going to be able to prove that this this
ai is in fact conscious and and sad
in any case and any more than you can
prove that a dog is conscious and sad
so it tells you that it is in good
language and you must believe it
but i think most people will accept
if faced with that that
that's what it is
all of this uh probability though of
complex life
i in one way i think
why it matters
is that
my expectation i suppose is that we we
will be
over the next hundred years or so if we
survive at all that ai will increasingly
dominate and and pretty much anything
that we put out into space going looking
for other
well for the universe for what's out
there
will be ai won't be won't be us we won't
be doing that or when we do it'll be on
a much more limited scale
i i suppose the same would apply to any
alien civilization so perhaps rather
than looking for signs of life out there
we should be looking for ai out there
but then we face the problem
um
that's
i don't see how a planet is going to
give rise directly to ai
we can see how a planet can give rise
directly to organic life
and if the principles that govern the
evolution of life on earth apply to
other planets as well
and i think a lot of them would
um
then the likelihood of ending up with
a human-like civilization capable of
giving rise to ai in the first place
is massively limited
once you've done it once perhaps it
takes over the universe and maybe uh
maybe there's no issue but it it seems
to me that the the the two are
necessarily linked that are you you're
not going to just turn a sterile planet
into an ai life form without the
intermediary of the organics first so
you have to run the the the full compute
the evolutionary computation with the
organics to create ai how does ai
bootstrap itself up without the aid if
you like of an intelligent designer
the origin of ai
is going to have to be in the chemistry
of a planet
so
but that's that's not a limiting factor
right so i mean so there's let me ask
the fermi paradox question
let's say we live in this incredibly
dark and beautiful world of
just
billions of planets with bacteria on it
and very few intelligent civilizations
and yet there's a few out there
why haven't we at scale seen them
visit us
what's your sense
is it because they don't exist um
because don't exist in the right part of
the universe at the right time that's
the simplest answer for it
is that the one you find the most
compelling or is there some other
explanation
i find that you know it's not that i
find it more compelling it's that i find
more probable uh and i find all of them
i mean there's a lot of hand waving in
this we just don't know
uh so so i'm trying to read out from
what i know about life on earth to what
might happen somewhere else
and it gives to my mind a bit of a
pessimistic view of bacteria everywhere
and only occasional intelligent life
and you know running forward humans only
once on earth and nothing else that you
would necessarily be
any more excited about making contact
with than you would be making contact
with them on earth
so
so i think the chances are pretty
limited
and the chances of us surviving
is pretty limited too the way we're
going on at the moment the likelihood of
us not making ourselves extinct within
the next few hundred years
possibly within the next 50 or 100 years
seems
quite small
i hope we can do better than that
um
so maybe the only thing that will
survive from humanity will be ai and
maybe once it exists and once it's
capable of
of effectively copying itself and
cutting humans out of the loop
um then maybe that will take over the
universe
i mean there's a kind of inherent
sadness to the way you describe that but
isn't that
also potentially beautiful that that's
the next step of life
um
i suppose as
from your perspective as long as it
carries the flame of consciousness
somehow i think yes there can be some
beauty to it being the next step of life
and i don't know if consciousness
matters or not from that point of view
to be honest with you
um
yeah but there's
there's some sadness yes probably
because
um
because i think it comes down to the
selfishness that we were talking about
earlier on i i am
an individual
with a a desire not to be kind of
displaced from life i want to stay alive
i want to
be here
um
so i suppose the threat that a lot of
people would feel is that we will just
be wiped out so that we will be um that
there will be potential conflicts
between ai and humans and that that hey
i will win because it's a lot smarter
boy would that be a sad state of affairs
if
consciousness is just an intermediate
stage
between bacteria and a.i
so i would see bacteria as being
potentially a kind of primitive form of
consciousness right so maybe the whole
of life on earth to my mind is conscious
it's capable of some form of feelings in
response to the environment that's not
to say it's intelligent though he's
got his own
algorithms for intelligence but nothing
comparable with us
i think it's beautiful what a planet
what a sterile planet can come up with
and it's astonishing that it's come up
with all of this stuff that we see
around us and and that either we
or whatever we produce is capable of
destroying all of that
yeah is it is a sad thought
but it's also
it's hugely pessimistic
i'd like to think that we're capable of
giving rise to something which is at
least as good if not better than us as
ai
yeah i i have that same
[Music]
i have the same optimism
especially a thing that is able to
propagate throughout the universe more
efficiently than humans can
or extensions of humans
some merger with ai in humans
whether that comes from
bioengineering of the human body to
extend its life
somehow
to carry that flame of consciousness and
that personality and the beautiful
tension
that's within all of us carry that
through to multiple planets to multiple
solar systems
all out there in the universe i mean
that's a beautiful that's a beautiful
vision whether ai can do that or
uh bioengineered humans
uh can that's an exciting possibility
and especially meeting other
other alien civilizations in that same
kind of way do you think do you think
aliens have consciousness if they're
organic
so organic yes connected to caution i
mean i i think any any system which is
going to bootstrap itself up from
planetary origins i mean
let me finish this and then come onto
something else but uh from from
planetary origins is going to face
similar constraints and those
constraints are going to be addressed in
similar basic engineering ways and i
think it will be cellular and i think it
will have electrical charges and i think
it will have to
be selected in populations over time and
all of these things will tend to give
rise to the same processes as the
simplest fix to a difficult problem so i
would expect it to be conscious yes and
i would expect it to
resemble life on earth in
many ways
when i was about i guess 15 or 16 i
remember reading a book by fred hoyle
called the black cloud
which
i was a budding biologist at the time
and this was the first time i'd come
across someone really challenging the
heart of biology and saying
you're you are far too parochial you you
know you're thinking about life as
carbon based here's a here's a life form
which is kind of dust interstellar dust
that on a on a on a solar system scale
um
and i
you know it's a novel but i felt
enormously challenged by that novel
because i hadn't occurred to me
how limited my thinking was
uh how how
narrow-minded i was being and he was it
was a great physicist with a completely
different conception of what life could
be
and since then i've seen him attacked uh
in in various ways and i
i'm kind of reluctant to say the attacks
make more sense to me than than the
original story which is to say
even in terms of
information processing if you're on that
scale and there's a limit of the speed
of light how quickly can something think
if you're needing to
broadcast across the
the the solar system
is going to be slow it's not going to
hold a conversation with you on the kind
of timelines that fred hoyle was
imagining at least not by
any easy way of doing it assuming that
speed of light is a limit
um
and and then again you
you really can't this is something
richard dawkins argued long ago and i do
think he's right there is no other way
to generate this level of complexity
than natural selection nothing else can
do it you need populations
and you need selection in populations
and a kind of an isolated
um
interstellar
cloud
again it's unlimited time and maybe
there's no problems with distance but
you need to have
a certain frequency of generational time
to generate a serious level of
complexity
um and
i just have a feeling it's never going
to work
well
as far as we know so natural selection
evolution is really powerful tool here
on earth but there could be other
mechanisms so whenever
i don't know if you're familiar with
cellular automata
but complex systems that
have really simple components
and seemingly move based on simple rules
when they're taken as a whole
really interesting complexity emerges
i don't know what the pressures on that
are it's not really selection but
interesting complexity seems to emerge
and that's not well understood exactly
why is that the difference between
complexity and evolution
so some of the work we're doing on the
origin of life is is is thinking about
how does
uh well how do genes arise how does
information arise in biology
and thinking about it from the point of
view of reacting co2 with hydrogen what
do you get well what you're going to get
is
carboxylic acids then amino acids it's
quite hard to make nucleotides
um and
it's possible to make them and it's been
done and it's being done following this
pathway as well but you make trace
amounts
and so the next question assuming that
this is the right way of seeing the
question which maybe it's just not but
let's assume it is
is well how do you reliably make more
nucleotides and how do you become more
complex and better at
becoming a nucleotide generating machine
and the answer is well you need positive
feedback loops
some form of auto catalysis so
that can work and we know it happens in
biology if this nucleotide for example
catalyzes co2 fixation then you're going
to increase the rate of flux through the
whole system and you're going to
effectively steepen the driving force to
make more nucleotides
um
and this can be inherited because
there are forms of membrane heredity
that you can have and there are
effectively you can if a cell divides in
two and it's got a lot of stuff inside
it and that stuff is basically bound as
a
network which is capable of regenerating
itself
then it will
inevitably regenerate itself and so you
can develop greater complexity
but everything that i've said depends on
the underlying rules of thermodynamics
there is no evolvability about that it's
simply an inevitable
outcome of your starting point
assuming that you're able to
increase the driving force through the
system you will generate more of the
same you'll expand on what you can do
but you'll never get anything different
than that and it's only when you
introduce
information into that as a gene as a as
a kind of
small stretch of rna
which can be random stretch
then you get real evolvability then you
get biology as we know it but you also
have selection as we know it
yeah i mean i don't know how to think
about information
um that's the kind of memory of the
systems it's not
yet at the local level it's propagation
of copying yourself and changing and
improving your adaptability to the
environment
but if you look at earth
as a whole
it has a kind of memory that's the key
feature of it
in my way
it remembers the stuff it tries
like if you were to describe earth
i i think evolution is something that we
experience
uh as individual organisms
that's that's how the individual
organisms interact with each other
there's a natural selection
but when you look at earth as an
organism
in its entirety
um
how would you describe it i mean well
not as an organism
i mean the idea of gaia is is lovely
and james lovelock originally put gaia
out as a as an organism that had somehow
evolved uh and he was immediately
attacked by lots of people
and he's not wrong but he backpedaled
somewhat because that was more of a
poetic vision than than um than than the
science
the science is now called earth systems
science and it's really about how does
the the world kind of regulate itself so
it remains within the limits which are
hospitable to life and it does it
amazingly well and it is it is working
at a planetary level
of
um
of of kind of integration of regulation
but it's not evolving by natural
selection and it can't because there's
only one of it um and so it can change
over time but it's not evolving all the
evolution is happening in the parts of
the system
yeah but it's a self-sustaining organism
no it's stained by the
sun right so i mean the so you don't
think it it's possible to see
earth as its own organism
i think it's poetic and beautiful and i
often refer to the to the earth as
living planet
but it's not in in biological terms an
organism no
if aliens were to visit earth
would they what would they notice
what would be the basic unit of life
they would notice trees probably i mean
it's green it's green and blue i think
that's the first thing you'd notice is
it stands out from space as being
different to any of the other planets
they would notice the trees at first
because the ground i would i noticed the
green yes yeah
and then uh probably notice
figure out the photosynthesis and then
you notice cities second i suspect
first
they arrived at night they noticed it at
first that's for sure it depends depends
the time you uh you write quite
beautifully in uh transformers once
again i think you open the book in this
way i don't remember
from space
describing earth
it's such an interesting idea of what
earth is um you also
i mean uh hitchhiker's guide summarizing
it is harmless or mostly harmless it's a
beautifully poetic thing
you
open transformers with from space
it looks gray and crystalline
obliterating the blue green colors of
the living earth
it is crisscrossed by irregular patterns
and convergent striations
there's a central amorphous density
where these scratches seem lighter
this quote growth does not look alive
although it has extended out along some
lines and there is something grasping
and parasitic about it
across the globe there are thousands of
them
varying in shape and detail but all of
them gray angular inorganic
spreading
yet at night they light up
going up the dark sky suddenly beautiful
perhaps these cankers on the landscape
are in some sense living there's a
controlled flow of energy there must be
information and some form of metabolism
some turnover of materials are they
alive
no of course not they are cities
so is there some sense that cities are
living beings
you think aliens would think of them as
living beings well it would be easy to
see it that way wouldn't it
um
it uh wakes up at night they wake up
it's strictly nocturnal
yes
i imagine that any aliens that are smart
enough to get here would understand that
uh they're they're not living beings
my reason for
saying that is that
we
tend to think of
biology in terms of information and
forget about cells
and i was trying to draw a comparison
between the cell as a city and and the
energy flow through the city and the
energy flow through cells and the
turnover of materials
and an interesting thing about cities
is that they're not really
exactly governed by anybody
um there are
regulations and systems and whatever
else but it's pretty loose
um
they have their own life their own way
of developing over time they they
and in that sense they're quite
biological
they're not it's there was there was a
plan
after the great fire of london
christopher wren was uh was making plans
not only for saint paul's cathedral but
also to rebuild in in large parisian
type boulevards a large part of the area
of central london that was uh was was
was burned
and it never happened
because they didn't have enough money i
think but it's interesting what was in
the plan were all these boulevards um
but there were no pubs and no coffee
houses or anything like that
and the reality was london just kind of
grew up in a
set of jumbled streets and it was the
coffee houses and the pubs where all the
business of the city of london was being
done and that was where the real life of
the city was and no one had planned it
the whole thing was unplanned and works
much better that way and in that sense
the cell is completely unplanned it's
not controlled by the genes in the
nucleus in the way that we might like to
think that it is but it's it's kind of
evolved entity that uh has the same kind
of flux the same animation the same life
so i think it's it's a it's a beautiful
analogy
but i wouldn't get
too stuck with it as a as a matter of
fact see i disagree with you i i i
disagree with you i i think you're
you are so steeped
and actually the entirety of
science
the history of science is steeped
in a biological framework of thinking
about what is life and not just
biological is very human-centric too
that human
the human organism is the epitome of
life
on earth i don't i don't know i i think
there is some deep fundamental way in
which a city is a living being
in the same way that
huma
it doesn't give rise to an offspring
city
it's so i mean it's not it doesn't work
by natural selection it works by if
anything means it works by
um yeah but isn't it
itself conceptually as a
mode of being
so i mean maybe memes maybe ideas are
are the organisms that are really
essential to life on earth maybe it's
much more important about the collective
aspect of human nature the collective
intelligence than the individual
intelligence maybe
the collective humanity is the organism
and the the thing that that defines the
collective intelligence of humanity is
the ideas
and maybe the way that manifests itself
is cities
maybe uh or societies or geographically
constrained societies or nations and all
that kind of stuff i mean from an alien
perspective it's possible that that is
the more
deeply noticeable thing not from a place
of but what's noticeable doesn't tell
you how it works
i i think i mean i don't have any
problem with what you're saying really
except that
it's not possible
without the humans you know we we went
from a hunter-gatherer's type
economy if you like without cities
through to cities and as soon as we get
into human evolution and culture and
society and so on then then then yes
there are other forms of evolution
uh the forms of change
um but but cities don't don't directly
propagate themselves they propagate
themselves through human societies and
human societies only exist because
humans as individuals propagate
themselves
so there's a kind of there is a
hierarchy there and without the humans
in the first place none of the rest of
it exists it says you
life is primarily defined by the the
basic unit on which evolution can
operate and that's a really unknown
thing yes
yeah
uh and we don't know we don't have any
other better ideas than evolution for
how to create i never came across a
better idea than evolution but i mean
maybe maybe i'm just ignorant and i
don't know and there's
you know you mentioned that's automator
and so on and
i don't think specifically about that
but i have thought about it in terms of
selective units at the origin of life
and the difference between evolvability
and and complexity or just increasing
complexity but within very narrow
narrowly defined limits
the great thing about
about genes and about selection is it
just knocks down all those limits it
gives you a world of information in the
end which is limited only by
the the biophysical reality of what what
kind of an organism you are what kind of
a planet you live on and so on
and and cities and and all these other
forms that look alive and could be
described as alive
because they can't propagate themselves
can only exist in
as the product of something that did
propagate itself
yeah
i mean there's a deeply compelling truth
to that kind of way of looking at things
but i just hope that we don't miss
the uh giant cloud
among us i i kind of hope that i'm wrong
about a lot of this because i can't say
that
my world view is particularly uplifting
um but in some sense
it doesn't matter if it's uplifting or
not science is about what's what's
reality what's what's out there why is
it this way
uh and and i'm
i think there's beauty in that too
there's beauty in darkness
you write about life and death
uh sort of at the biological level is
does the question of suicide why live
does the question of why the human mind
is capable of depression are you able to
um introspect that from a place of
biology
why
our minds why we humans can go to such
dark places
why can we commit suicide
why can we
go
um you know suffer
suffer period but also suffer from
a feeling of meaninglessness of um going
to a dark place that depression can take
you is this a feature of life or is it a
bug
um i don't know i mean if it's a feature
of life then i suppose it would have to
be true of other organisms as well and i
don't know
we were talking about dogs earlier on
and they can certainly be
uh very
sad and upset and may mooch for days
after their owner died or something like
that so i suspect in some sense it's a
feature of biology
um
it's probably a feature of mortality
it's probably
but beyond all of that
i mean i guess there's two ways you
could come at it there's one of them
would be to say well
you can effectively do do the math and
come to the conclusion that it's all
pointless and there's really no point in
me being here any longer
um
and maybe that's true in the greater
scheme of things
you can justify yourself in terms of
society but society will be gone soon
enough as well and you end up with a
very bleak place just by
logic in some sense it's surprising that
we can find any meaning at all
well maybe this is where consciousness
comes in that we we have transient joy
but with transient joy we have transient
misery as well and and sometimes
with everything in biology
um
getting the regulation right is
practically impossible
you will always have a bell-shaped curve
where some people unfortunately are at
the joy end and some people are at the
misery end and
you know that's the way brains are wired
and
i i doubt there's ever an escape from
that it's the same with sex and
everything else as well we're dealing
with it whether whether you know you you
can't regulate it so
it's um
any anything goes it's all part of
biology
amen to that
let me uh
on writing
in uh
your book power sex and suicide first of
all can i just read off the books you've
written
if there's any better titles and topics
to be covered i don't know what they are
it makes me look forward to whatever
you're going to write next i hope
there's
things you write next so you first you
wrote oxygen the molecule that made the
world as we've talked about this
idea of the role of oxygen in life on
earth then wait for it
power sex suicide mitochondria and the
meaning of life
then life ascending the 10 great
inventions of evolution the vital
question the first book i've read of
yours the vital question why is life the
way it is and the new book transformer
the deep chemistry of life and death
in uh power sex and suicide
you write about writing or about a lot
of things but i i have a question about
writing
you write
in the hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
ford perfect spends 15 years researching
his revision to the guide's entry on the
earth which originally read
harmless
by the way i would also as a side quest
as a side question would like to ask you
what would be your summary of what earth
is
you're right his long essay on the
subject is edited down by the guide to
read
mostly harmless
i suspect that
too many new additions suffer similar
fate if not through absurd editing
decisions at least through a lack of
meaningful change in content as it
happens nearly 15 years have passed
since the first edition of power sex
suicide was published and i am resisting
the temptation to make any lame
revisions
some say that even darwin lessen the
power of his arguments in the origin of
species there's multiple revisions in
which he dealt with criticisms and
sometimes shifted his views in the wrong
direction
i prefer my original to speak for itself
even if it turns out to be wrong
let me ask the question about writing
both your students in the academic
setting but also writing some of the
most brilliant writings on science and
humanity i've ever read what's the
process of
writing how how do you advise
other humans
if you if you were to talk to young
darwin or the young young you
and uh just young anybody and give
advice about how to write and how to
write well about these big topics what
would you say
i said i mean i suppose there's a couple
there's a couple of
points one of them is um
what's the story
what do i want to know what do i want to
convey
why does it matter to anybody
and and very often the most
the biggest most interesting questions
um
the child-like
questions
are the
the one actually that everybody wants to
ask but don't quite do it in case they
look stupid um and one of the nice
things about being in science is you the
more the longer you're in the more you
realize that everybody doesn't know the
answer to these questions and it's not
so stupid to ask them after all yes um
so
so trying to ask the questions that
i would have been asking myself at the
age of 15 16 when i when i was really
hungry to know about the world and
didn't know very much about it and and
um
wanted to be
wanted to go to the edge of what we know
but
um
but be helped to get there i i don't
want to be you know
too much terminology and so i i want
someone to keep a clean eye on what the
question is
um
beyond that
i i've wondered a lot i've about who who
am i writing for
and that was in the end
the only answer i had was was myself at
the age of 15 or 16. 16
because
even if you're you know you can
you just don't know who who's reading
but also where are they reading it
are they reading it in the bath or in
bed or on the on the metro or or
are they listening to an audiobook
do you want to have a
you know a recapitulation
every few pages because you read three
pages at a time or or are you really
irritated by that you know you're going
to get criticism
from people who are irritated by what
you're doing and you don't know who they
are or what you're going to do that's
going to irritate people and in the end
all you can do is just try and
please yourself
and that means what are these big fun
fascinating in big questions
and what do we know about it
and and can i convey that and i kind of
learned in trying to write
um first of all
say what we know
and i was shocked in the first couple of
books how often i came up quickly
against all the stuff we don't know
uh and if you're trying to
i've realized later on in in in
in supervising various physicists and
mathematicians who are phd students and
i you know their math is way beyond what
i can do
but the process of trying to work out
what are we actually going to model here
what's going into this equation is a
very similar one to writing what am i
going to put on a page what's the
simplest possible way i can encapsulate
this idea so that i now have it as a
unit that i can kind of see how it
interacts with the other units
and you realize that well if this is
like that and this is like this then
then that can't be true
um
so you end up navigating your own path
through this landscape and that can be
thrilling because you don't know where
it's going
um
and i'd like to think that that's one of
the reasons my books have worked for
people because this sense of the
thrilling adventure ride i don't know
where it's going either
so the finding the simplest possible way
to explain the things we know and the
simplest possible way to explain the
things we don't know and the tension
between those two and that's where the
story emerges
what about the edit
do you find yourself
to the point of this
uh
you know editing dial to mostly harmless
to arrive at simplicity do you find
the edit as productive or does it
destroy the the magic that was
originally there
no i usually find i i think i'm perhaps
a better editor than i am a writer i i
write and rewrite and rewrite and
rewrite put a bunch of crap on the page
first and then see
the edit where it takes yeah
but then then there's the professional
editors who come along as well and um i
mean
in in transformer um
the editor came back to me uh after i
sent him two months after i sent the
first edition he'd read the whole thing
and he said
the first two chapters prevent a
formidable hurdle to the general reader
go and do something about it yes and
it was the last thing i really wanted
your editor sounds very eloquent in
speech yeah well this wasn't this was an
email but uh i i i i thought about it
and you know the bottom line is he was
right
and so i put the whole thing aside for
about two months
uh spent the summer this would have been
i guess last summer
uh and then turned to it with full
attention in about september or
something and rewrote those chapters
almost from scratch i kept some of the
material but
it took me a long time to process it to
work out what needs to change where does
it need to i wasn't writing in this time
how am i going to tell this story better
so it's more accessible and interesting
and in the end
i think it was still it's still
difficult it's still biochemistry but
but it has he ended up saying now he's
got a barreling energy to it and i was
you know because he'd been because he
told me the truth the first time i
decided to believe that he was telling
me the truth the second time as well and
was was
delighted
could you give advice to young people in
general
uh folks in high school folks in college
how to take on some of the big questions
you've taken on now you've done that in
the space of biology and expanded out
how can they
have a career they can be proud of or
have a life they can be proud of
gosh
that's a big question
i'm um i'm sure you've gathered some
wisdom
you can um impart
yeah just so the only advice that i
actually ever give to my students
um is
follow what you're interested in
because they they're often
worried that if they make this decision
now and and do this course instead of
that course then they're going to
restrict their career opportunities and
um
there isn't a career path in science
it's it's not i mean that there is but
there isn't um
there's a lot of competition there's a
lot of death
symbolically
um so who survives
the people who survive are the people
who
care
enough
to still do it and they're very often
the people who
don't worry too much about the future
and are able to live in the present
because if you you know you do a phd
you've competed hard to get onto the phd
then you have to compete hard to get a
post-doc job and
you have you know the next bond maybe on
another continent and it's only two
years anyway and and so and there's no
there's no uh guarantee you're going to
get a faculty position at the end of it
so and there's always the next step to
compete if you get a faculty position
you get a tenure and with 10 you go full
professor and full professor then you go
to some kind of whatever the discipline
is there's an award if you're in physics
you're always competing for the nobel
prize there's different awards yeah and
then eventually you're all competing to
i mean there's always a competition so
there is no happiness happiness does not
lie if you're looking into the future
yes and if what you're caring about is a
career then then
it's probably not the one for you
if though you can put that aside and you
know i've also worked in industry for a
brief period and uh and i was made
redundant twice so i i know that uh that
you know there's no guarantee she got a
career that way either yes
so
so
live in the moment
and try and enjoy what you're doing and
that means really
go to the
go to the themes that you're most
interested in and try and follow them as
well as you can and and that
tends to pay back in surprising ways i
don't know if you've found this as well
but i i found that
um
people will help you often if they
see some light shining in the eye
and you're excited about their subject
um
and and you know just want to talk about
it
and they know that their friend in
california's got a job coming up they'll
say go for this this guy's all right you
know
they'll they'll they'll use the network
to help you out if you really care and
you're not going to have a job two years
down the line but if you what you really
care about is what you're doing now
then it doesn't matter if you have a job
in two years time or not it'll work
itself out if you've got the light in
your eye
um and so
that's the only advice i can give and
most people
probably
drop out through that system because the
fight is just not worth it for them
yeah when you have the light in your eye
when you have the excitement for the
thing what happens is you start to
surround yourself with others they're
interested in that same thing that also
have the light if you really are
rigorous about this because i think it
does take it's it doesn't
it takes effort
to make oh you've got to be obsessive
but but if you're doing what you really
love doing then it's not work anymore
it's what you do yeah but i also mean
the surrounding yourself with other
people that are obsessed about the same
thing because
depending on that takes some work as
well yeah you know and look finding the
right yeah finding the right mentors the
collaborators because i think one of the
problem with
the phd processes
people are not careful enough in picking
their mentors those are people
mentors and colleagues and so on those
are people going to define
the the direction of your life
how much you love a thing how much i
mean the power of just like the few
little conversations you have
in the hallway
it's it's incredible so you have to be a
little bit careful in that
sometimes you just get randomly almost
assigned um
really
pursue
i suppose the subject
as much as you pursue the people that do
that subject so like both the whole
dance of it they kind of go together
really yeah they do they really do but
take that that
that part seriously and probably in the
way you're describing it
careful how you define success
because uh you'll never find happiness
in success and there's a lovely quote uh
from robert lewis stevenson i think who
said nothing in life is so disenchanting
as attainment
yeah so i mean in in some sense
the the the true definition of success
is
you're getting to do today
what you really enjoy doing just uh what
fills you with joy and that's ultimately
success so success isn't the thing
beyond the horizon the big stat the the
the big trophy the the financial i think
it's it's as close as we can get to
happiness that's not to say you're full
of joy all the time but it's it's as
close as we can get to a sustained human
happiness is by getting some fulfillment
from what you're doing on a daily basis
and if what you're looking for
is the
the the world giving you the stamp of
approval with a nobel prize or a
fellowship or whatever it is then
you know i've known people like this who
they
they're eaten away by the
by the anger kind of caustic
resentment that they've not been awarded
this prize that they deserve
and the other way if you put too much
value into those kinds of prizes and you
win them
i've got the chance to see
that it also
the more quote-unquote successful you
are in that sense the more you run the
danger of
um
growing ego so big that you don't get to
actually
enjoy the beauty of this life you start
to believe that you figured it all out
as opposed to
i think what the ultimately the most fun
thing is is being curious about
everything around you being constantly
surprised and uh these little moments of
discovery of enjoying enjoying beauty in
small and big ways all around you and i
think the bigger your ego grows the more
you start to take yourself seriously the
less you're able to enjoy that oh man i
couldn't agree more
um so you know the the summary from
harmless to mostly harmless
in hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy how
would you try to summarize
earth and um
you know if you were given
if you have to summarize the whole thing
in in a couple of sentences and maybe
throwing meaning of life in there like
what why why
why
maybe is that a defining thing about
humans that we care about the meaning
of the whole thing
i wonder i wonder if that should be part
of the the the these creatures seem to
be very lost
yes they're always asking why i mean
that's my defining question is why
it was uh
people used to made a joke i have a
small scar on my forehead from a
climbing accident years ago
uh and the guy i was climbing with had
dislodged a rock and he shouted
something he shot below i think meaning
that the rock was coming down
and uh and i hadn't caught what he said
so i looked up and smashed straight on
my forehead and um and everybody around
me
took the piss saying he he looked up to
ask why
yeah but that that's a human imperative
that's part of what it means to be human
look up to the sky and ask why
and ask why
uh so your question defined the earth
i'm not sure i can do that i mean the
first word that comes to mind is living
i wouldn't like to say mostly living but
perhaps
mostly well it's interesting because
like if you were to to write the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
i suppose
say our idea
uh that we talked about the bacteria is
the most prominent form of life
throughout
the galaxy in the universe
i suppose the earth would be kind of
unique
and would require abundance in that case
yeah it's profligate it's rich it's
enormously enormously living
so how how would you describe that it's
not bacteria
it's
um
eukaryotic
yeah well i mean that's that's the
technical term but it is basically it's
uh
uh
yeah and then how would i describe that
i i've i've actually really struggled
with that term because
the word i mean there's a few words
quite as good as eukaryotic to put
everybody off immediately you start
using words like that and they'll leave
the room
a krebs cycle is another one that gets
people to leave the room
but
um
but i've tried to think is there another
word for eukaryotic that i can use and
really the only word that i've i've been
able to use is complex
complex cells
uh complex life and so on and that word
it it serves one immediate purpose which
is to convey
an impression
but then it it
it means so many different things just
everybody
that actually is lost immediately and so
it's kind of
well that's unnoticeable from the
perspective of other planets that is the
noticeable
face transition of complexity is the
eukaryotic
what about the harmless and the mostly
harmless is that kind of
probably accurate on a on a universal
kind of scale
i don't think that uh
humanity is in any danger of disturbing
the universe at the moment at the moment
which is why the mostly
we don't know depends what elon is up to
that's how many rockets i think uh it'll
be still even then a while
i think before uh before we disturb the
fabric of
time and space was the aforementioned
andrei carpathi i think he summarized
earth
as um
as a system
where you uh hammer it with a bunch of
photons
the input is like photons and the output
is rockets
see if you just
well that's a hell of a lot of photons
before it was a rocket launcher yeah
but like
you know maybe maybe in the span of the
universe it's not it's not that much
time
and so and i do wonder
you know what the future is whether
we're just in the early beginnings of
this earth
which is important when you try to
summarize it
or we're at the end
where humans have finally
gained the ability to destroy
the entirety of this beautiful project
we got going on
now with nuclear weapons with engineered
viruses with all those kinds of things
or just inadvertently through global
warming and pollution and so on
we're quite capable of i mean we just
need to slowly
i mean i think we're more likely to do
it inadvertently than than through a
nuclear war which could happen at any
time but um
my fear is
is we just don't know where the tipping
points are and we will
we we kind of think we're smart enough
to fix the problem quickly if we really
need to i think that's that's the
overriding assumption that
we're all right for now maybe in 20
years time it's going to be a calamitous
problem and then we'll really need to
put some serious mental power into
fixing it
without seriously worrying that perhaps
that is too late
and that
however brilliant we are
it's uh we missed the boat
and just walk off the cliff
i don't know i have optimism in humans
being clever
descendants oh i have no doubt that we
can fix the problem
but it's an urgent problem
and we we need to fix it pretty sharpish
and i i do have doubts about whether
politically we are capable of coming
together enough to uh
not just
in any one country but around the planet
to just i mean i know we can do it but
do we have the will do we have the the
the vision to uh to accomplish it that's
what makes this whole
ride fun i don't know
not only do we not know if we can handle
the crises before us
we don't even know all the crisis that
are going to be before us in the next 20
years the the ones i think that will
most likely challenge us
in the 21st century are the ones we
don't even expect people didn't expect
world war ii at the end of world war one
uh
well
yeah not at the end of world war one but
by the 19 late 1920s i think people were
beginning to worry about it yeah no
there's always people worrying about
everything yeah so if you focus on the
thing that people worry about yes
because there's a million things people
worry about it and
99.99 of them don't come to be of course
the people that turn out to be right
they'll say i knew all along but that's
not you know that's not an accurate way
of knowing what sean could have
predicted i think rationally speaking
you can worry about it but nobody
thought you could have another world war
the war to end all wars why would you
have another war and the idea of nuclear
weapons
just technologically is a very difficult
thing to anticipate to create a weapon
that just jumps orders the magnitude and
destructive capability
and of course we can intuit all the
things like engineered viruses
nanobots artificial intelligence
yes all the different
complicated global effects of global
warming so how that changes the
allocation of resources the flow of
energy the tension between countries the
military conflict between countries the
reallocation of power then looking at
the role of china in this whole thing
with with russia and growing influence
of africa and the weird dynamics of
europe and then america falling apart
through the political division fueled by
uh recommender systems through twitter
and facebook the whole beautiful mess
is just fun and i think there's a lot of
incredible engineers incredible
scientists incredible human beings
that while everyone is bickering and so
on online for the fun of it on the
weekends they're actually trying to
build solutions and those are the people
that will create something beautiful at
least i have
you know that's the process of evolution
it's uh
there was it all started with a chuck
norris
uh
single cell organism that went out from
the vents
and was the parent to all of us
and for for that guy or lady or both i
guess
is a big thank you and i can't wait to
what happens next and i'm glad there's
incredible humans writing and studying
it like you are nick it's a huge honor
that you would talk to me this was
fantastic this is really amazing i can't
wait
uh to read what you write next uh thank
you for existing
um
and um thank you for talking today
thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with nick lane to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from steve jobs
i think the biggest innovations of the
21st century will be at the intersection
of biology and technology
a new era is beginning
thank you for listening i hope to see
you next time